you
welcome everyone this meeting of the Huntsville City Council is called together it is Friday
September 18th 2026 it is 11 o'clock p.m. we are meet met in the chambers of the Huntsville
City Council in Huntsville Alabama this is a work session of the City Council no action
will be taken and items will be considered at the September 24th regular Council meeting
Madam President point of order I just want to for the record descend and object to this
unilateral alteration and downgrading of a special session into a non voting work session
thank you Mr. Meredith your objection is noted we'll move forward with the agenda following
introductory comments by the mayor will have presentation of the fiscal year 2027 budget
followed by presentation from the administration on changes to the organization of the staff
and then we will hear regarding a change in classification and salary plan ordinance followed
finally by presentations of the fiscal year 2027 2014 capital improvement plan and the
year 2027 update to the 1990 capital plan mayor battle will begin with your comments thank you
Madam President and thank you Council this is always an interesting time I was kind of
reflecting on it sitting up here it's my 23rd time to go through a budget for the City of Huntsville
and over those 23 years we started off with budgets of about 35 million and today we are
we are a third of a billion dollars 330 million dollars as a budget and as we've done that we've
seen a growth in our community we've seen a growth in where we are we have never had a budget where
we have been able to fulfill everyone's everyone's what what everyone asks for each year we have
this much resources and we have this much wants in our community and they're good wants the wants
out there are projects that we look at each each and every year they're projects that you you wish
you could you could afford but you can't and we have to come in with a balanced budget by law we
are required to come in with a balanced budget and that's what we will present to you today
there's going to be a lot on the plate today it's anticipated that just there's there's a lot to look
at everything from our revenue sides and where we are in revenue and uh miss smith go through that
with you to our expenses to our payroll we have a two percent cola worked in this we also have some
increases in some areas that we feel like it's very important to increase so that we can
stay competitive in in that job market out there as as we try to make sure that we have proper
public safety we have outside agencies who came in and there you know we have definitely not met
the needs of all the outside agencies we had agency after agency requests we had more agencies
requests this year i think than we've ever had and uh and we tried to be very judicious as we
went through to make sure that we um allocated that money that was there about a 10 of our budget
kind of like in your church uh 10 type 10 of that budget went to uh outside agencies and uh those
outside agencies are important agencies to us but there are many more that are just as important who
uh were not able to be funded this year um we're also you'll have the cap plan the 2014 and the
1990 capital plan this is something that's very unique that a lot of communities don't have
across alabama across the u.s we have two funds which are dedicated to the growth of our community
one fund the 2014 capital plan some of y'all were here when we passed that 2014 capital plan
dedicated towards uh roads and economic development uh the 1990 capital plan is dedicated towards
internal facilities for the city of huntsville uh the the kind of quality of life issues or
the quality of life facilities that you put up a lot of the sandra moon a lot of the uh pickleball
courts a lot of a lot of the shirney center others like that were all put into uh the 1990 capital
plan and it gives us a source of funding so that we can fund the continued growth of our city
um you also have a reorgan here as uh as i've talked to each of you over the last uh
uh last couple of months uh mr davis is leaving the city and we'll miss him uh miss sorely miss
him but out of that uh has come a good bit of talk about succession planning how do we set up our
government so that we are not having a one person fail safe uh that we have people who can back up
other people who can back up other people and uh if if something happens to somebody we can
fill that slot and we can keep moving forward and so the reorganization is uh coming back to an idea
that we honestly need to look very much at succession uh and make sure that we have uh
people in line and people in place when i start looking for people to put in place for some of
that succession i look for number one internal uh because we have a great bench internally we have
some great people uh work for the city of huntsville and we want to make sure that those
those folks are given the first shot if something you know if there's a place that we just don't
have don't feel like we have the right person for it then we'll go external we'll go uh you know
with a nationwide search and uh interviews and after those interviews we may end up with somebody
internal we may end up with somebody uh from uh from anywhere in the u.s but we want to get the
best people because that's what the citizens of huntsville ask us for it where government is no
better than the people that we have so uh i will say to you uh today that i thank you for your
time and your patience with this this will take a little bit of time but i think it's something
that's very important for our future to make sure that as we um put together our budget and put
together our financial plans for for the next year that we're ready for what the future brings us
future looks very very bright uh the future looks good to us uh but we have to make sure that
day in and day out that we take care of the little things that we take care of the little things
the big things get taken care of and uh our community will continue to grow continue to
thrive but continue to offer opportunity to people uh opportunity for jobs opportunity uh
to be part of a growing economy and we want to make sure that every section of the city is part
of that uh growth and that opportunity so thank you thank you mayor battled we'll now uh move on
to the first item on a long agenda 1b is a presentation of the proposed fiscal year 2027
budget by the administration followed by increased discussion and input by city council
with the mayor and administration officials and the presentation will be given by our
cfo miss penny smith
i want to say good evening but it's really um good morning so um thank you i'm penny smith
uh finance director here in the city and um and i get to present this wonderful budget to you
i'm very excited about it we're gonna get to delve into all the different facets of this budget
and there are many to look at so i appreciate your patience with me as i go through the things today
and also your questions and comments as we move move into that portion of this budget so um so i
do want to make a mention i do want to shout out to my absolutely amazing staff we're all geeks in
this and we love putting together this stuff but um but they in particular i want to call out budget
our budget manager jennifer hersey grants manager whitney gentry who is actually going to present
part of this today in addition to myself for outside agencies and then kim thick bin who's
put in a lot of work as our payroll manager on the different aspects of this budget
budget
so getting into the agenda a little bit and the mayor mentioned this as he as he talked um going
through a lot of ground to cover and we will start off with the budget creation and financial
structure and then just move deeper into the different different aspects of the budget
budget
so as the mayor mentioned the budget is a fiscal plan or a policy document and it is required of
us to present a balanced budget each year for for the general fund before the start of the next
fiscal year as the finance department and the finance director we are a facilitator in this
process we pull together a lot of different numbers and stack up a lot of different things
to make up the budget and there are many advisors and inputs from the different
experts in the city but the mayor makes all the final decisions this is his budget
and that is what i present to you this evening
so we're going to start with a little bit a little primer about um fiscal fund accounting and and so
that is where we'll land you've seen these before but this is just kind of a reminder
so the general fund is our largest fund in the city you can see all the revenue sources in the
departments that are housed in our general fund it has a lot going on and the different aspects
the total budget is 360.6 million dollars for the general fund it's where all the major activities
occur for all our departments besides the general fund housing these for for sources and uses
the city is self-insured and so we have a life health and life insurance fund it accounts for
about 40 million dollars in premium and um and health expense that goes through through the city
in addition we have an events donation fund that's called our revolving revolving fund
and it just houses anytime people donate to the city and say i want this to go for this specific
item and people can donate they can take that off on their taxes we actually place it into this
fund so things like jazz in the park cafe um the any other police programs and some other items
are housed in this fund special revenue funds are exactly kind of what the title alludes to
so these account for very specific revenue sources that are tied to that have legal
constraints against the way that we spend them and so first off is property tax funds we have
two of those they are both 6.5 mils and represent different aspects one is for the Huntsville city
schools and it is for it's budgeted in the amount of 41.7 million in property taxes this year and
then 6.5 mils are restricted for capital or infrastructure of the city it's at 36.9 million
this city has determined in its best interest to um to give a portion of sales and use tax to
our city school systems for their operating budget this year that amount is going to be
budgeted at 38.6 million dollars for furtherance of education the lodging tax fund so we had three
last year this year we have four because of the additional one percent i'm going to talk about
that a little bit later but all the revenue across the funds equals about 29.4 million dollars
we have three maybe four in the future tax increment financing districts three of which
right now in operation are five seven and nine i'm going to mention those a little bit later
tip eight is under consideration and has yet to be approved so appropriately it is actually not
in this budget total revenue projected for these three funds is 21 million then we have our gas
tax funds they are restricted for road bridge and repair and maintenance it can be used for street
lighting and in this case a lot of it is total revenue is forecasted at 8.8 million certain
other funds federal and state forfeiture funds can are restricted for public safety use
cemetery sales oh excuse me corrections and court funds are also restricted for their use in judicial
and then our cemetery sales and cares we actually had two last year we combined that to one
for efficiencies that was allowed by law and so so that is that is in the care of our cemeteries
spent in the care of that and then the last thing is our grants funds which includes cdbg home cni
are directed by community development and then the fta funds are directed by public and by
parking and public transit department they both together annually produce around five million dollars
in addition within that financial structure is our capital projects funds which you'll hear about
them later both 1990 and the 2014 as well as other debt funded projects so when we borrow we
put we take those borrows per our transcripts and we put those into a specific fund that way when
that borrowing is spent for the projects that are allocated out to that specific borrow then we close
that fund and that's the way we we keep up with all of that requirements for our borrowings
we also have two enterprise funds that will be presented tonight that are administered in
the inside the city our wpc which which is sewer collection and treatment and then the sanitation
fund for trash and and bulky trash waste that are also collected within the city the fiduciary fund
we have one which is also akin to our retiree health care fund so a lot of people call it opab
a lot of people call it opeb other post-employment benefits and and that is for our retirees it was
placed into a trust for a while back and it continues to earn interest in that a certain
portion of that of that expenditure was there and so so those are allocated to our fiduciary funds
so i always talk about what's kind of driving in our economy and so inflation outlook continues
to rise because of our energy cost and kind of uncertainty in the markets the current number for
inflation is a little over three percent job growth is rebounded in august but unemployment
rates are holding steady at 4.1 percent nationally but locally we always do better than that at 3.1
percent consumer consumer spending remains strong and is predicted to continue to hold and that
bodes well for us with the continuing resolutions that are already on the books laid out ahead of
the midterms this fall that bodes well for us going into the fall if you remember and you'll see it in
a lot of the slides we had a very weak fall because of the shutdowns in in the federal government
and so since we are a town that houses an arsenal and a lot of a lot of our jobs are are tied to that
that caused us to have some have some downturns in the fall but we expect that to be much better
this fall the federal reserve decided on wednesday to to raise the federal funds rate by a quarter
of basis point so it is now between 3.75 and four it's range it's designed to fight inflation over
the rising energy cost but for us that just means a little bit higher on our on our borrowing rates
and also a little bit higher in our investment income so both sides of the fence
so now we're going to get into revenues it's kind of the heart of our 27 budget all of this by the
way starts on page six many many many of these slides the graphics the charts that i present
are all contained in your budget book that you are that you have i hope you will take the time
to read the narratives along with that there's a lot of good information in there
so this chart lies on page six of your budget books and starts the section on revenues
excluding grants these seven sources make up right at 90 percent of all the revenue received
in the city and so they are very important to as we move through our budget this evening or sorry
this morning so i may do that a lot general fund sources we i throw this up there because
the slices of the pie and i'm actually going to live here for a little bit over the next couple
of slides the relationships are important this represents our general fund so if you'll notice
the gray and the gold slides are our sales and use tax for last year and this year it just fell just
under 50 percent which was which we're watching that so as other pieces of the pie get get a little
larger if you'll notice some other larger slices licensing is in the peach up there property taxes
make up about 11 percent and pilot revenue nine and then the ssut is at 7.2 i'm going to talk about
that in just a minute so i redesigned this and reconstructed this because it was a different
dynamic that i decided to look back over a few years and see where that went sales and use tax
as a whole is climbing as the numbers are climbing but as a percentage of the hole in the general
fund is declining it is being replaced by by an inclining ssut and property taxes so so while
our property tax base that bodes well as far as the growth in the assessed values and both and new
builds in our community ssut is controlled by the state it is a little bit worrisome to to be more
in control of a state a state controlled revenue source as opposed to our local locally assessed
taxes so for sales and use tax the the year-to-date collections are three percent ahead of prior year
and 2.8 percent above the revised budget at where we're into the last month of our physical year so
that should play into the remainder of the physical year we hope and and and looks very good you can
see those first couple of months were down especially in november we were under and we got
concerned but we seem to have come out and done well for the rest the remainder of the year
so this is a graphic you're going to see again and again in multiple slides so i just want to
walk you through the graphic real quick so the dark blue represents on actual years the aqua
teal i'm not sure what you want to call it is the projected amount for fy 26 and then what's in
green is our proposed out there to the far right so this is our sales and use tax at the time it
was 2.5 percent increased over the final projected numbers for 2026 and following the trends and stuff
we look like we will do fine kind of clearing the decks for the fall it is a reasonable assumption
that the next year the city will continue on current gains so that's why we we pull this this
source up and it continues to support the four funds that are listed there so i wanted to to
remind you a little bit of how ssut works so ssut is at eight percent if you buy online and are in
that particular if you buy online for particular businesses the the sales and use tax rate the
ssut rate is eight percent four percent goes to the state four percent goes to the city and county
which is then split out mainly by population of the counties 67 counties and 467 cities and towns
split by population for our local sales tax rate and i realize this is for madison county
it's a different in limestone county but the madison county's sales tax rate is four percent
goes to the state the state is made whole either way half percent goes to the county and 4.5 percent
goes to the city so a larger percentage which also bleeds into at the bottom here the sales and use
tax rate a hundred dollar purchase in the city of huntsville is creates four dollars and 50 cents to
the city for ssut that same hundred dollar purchase online creates eight cents to the city now it is
for the whole state but but it it makes a huge difference we are really looking towards the
state this year and as we continue to to look to look at the changes that we would like to see in
simplified seller's use tax and because we continue to to just lose money each year to ssut
the projected loss for fy 26 is 44 million our estimated loss to date is 333 million dollars
um for ssut and part of it is down there in that kind of purple box so the percentage of
online sales continues to grow more and more people order online i know i do for myself
it's um it's easy to sit in your home and and not go to a store and purchase things and you
just purchase it online so it makes it easier and easier so this is something that we've got to
continue to work with the state to find a solution and um for for our city's revenues
um
so bringing us kind of full circle back around to this year's budget
um the simplified seller's use revenue you can see that double digit increases every single year
for that is estimated to be at 15 percent increase to 25.9 million dollars
um
ad valorem or property taxes is also a large portion of our general fund uh this represents the 6.5
this represents all three of our 6.5 million um it is it is estimated as we go through that
it's under various provisions um for allocated for the schools and the cities as i talked about
earlier um property taxes investments continue to increase each year at an average of over 10
percent last year was a little complicated by the closure of three tiffs with the majority of those
of that going back to our city school systems but some will extend back to the city we do receive
ad valorem in now four counties for madison morgan limestone and marshall counties so um so but these
projections were completed based only on the limestone and the madison abstracts that we
received from those counties so just to talk about a little bit about tiffs there's been some concern
that how tiffs kind of affect those ad valorem taxes that we receive so in the recent past
at the end of 2025 we had five open tiffs two four five six and seven um you can see those are marked
out into in the city and then but then with the closure of two four and six it became this this
is our current status um tiff nine is our newest addition to to the tiff so we only have three
that are operating in the city and then with the addition of tiff eight that goes down there
in limestone and y'all are well aware as that moves through that process
that brings us to lodging taxes lodging tax revenue is located outside of the general fund
so now we're leaving the general fund i'm going outside um lodging tax remains closely watched
by staff as it points in real time to what people do with their excess funds and also
um also for commercial and defense industry and their travel to our area i want to talk
specifically about the one percent that was added so now our lodging tax rate is at 16
percent in total 10 going to the city that one percent that was passed recently begins on 10 one
and so collections will start in november but it is allocated toward the construction and
maintenance of the vbc in particular looking towards the new expansion of the vbc
towards the new expansion of the vbc
oops
this is how that tax has performed over the last year um in the last few years year-to-date
collections are about 0.3 behind the prior year and 0.4 percent ahead of budget with 91
percent of the year elapsed so i really need to point back to that fall that was pretty
devastating for this revenue source was that was that closure and so we should do well do better
this fall without the closure of our federal government
um pilot revenue we've had a lot of talk about pilot different pilot revenues and in in the
recent past i know that y'all have been y'all have received a few different uh memos and
and different information on pilot revenue the major sources of that is we have pilots for
i want to talk first about gas and water so those are set at six percent against the revenue
gross revenue that comes out of those systems so they are right now forecasted to be about
4.4 million each in the next year and then our electric system and our fiber system which we
have talked about quite a bit at the mid-year time is based on asset books booked assets and
the avalor taxes that would be against those assets within the system and so that is now
allocated to be much more level you can see in the graphic that the actual for fy 25 is 32.1
for 26 with the the deep dive that hunts for utilities did and that we we assisted with on
all of that for 26 it's going to be 32.4 million is that's where we think it's going to end the
year at and then the proposed for 27 is 32 is 32.8 mainly because of those increases with gas and
water i fully expect our electric and fiber should the construct not change to level out and even
decline a little bit in future years but we should hopefully stay pretty steady there there are some
other factors in the works that that we are looking at along with hunts for utilities
in pursuing some different avenues with tva
okay so this came out of the mid-year presentation and it was just specific to
to that downturn i put this in here to help kind of understand where that the electric and the fiber
system is that i'm not going to go through that so other revenue sources
so while much smaller in in many cases that they are still really important to our
to our revenue streams and to the different work that we do within the city
we mentioned pilots licenses are a lagging indicator of the economy as the majority is
based on the prior year spending so based on these trends we expect this to increase a little to 31
million dollars this year for gas taxes up in your upper right hand corner list all the multiple
sources of the gas tax types all are assessed at the state level and distributed back to the
local cities and counties based on a formula they can pay for roads bridges and other similar
expenditures revenues kind of rise and fall based on fuel prices and the consumption in the economy
and with prices as they continue to grow this year we've proposed just a small increase at two
point at 7.2 million mainly because of the population increase into into our city i want
to note here that a major a majority of this is spent on road resurfacing however we do dedicate
a portion of that to street lighting the cost has outstripped the revenue since 21 so the general
fund budgets a transfer in the amount of 2.9 million this year to support the cost for fy 27
investment income interest in investment income has come to play an important role in our general
fund budgets in order to support the general fund it was decided to dedicate some appropriate
interest streams back to the general fund that means that for fy 26 and fy 27 the interest income
has doubled for the general fund in addition to these revenue streams the alabama trust fund
which is based on oil and gas revenues that came into the city they said came into the state they
set that up in a trust and then decided to move back the earnings on that to all the different
cities and counties based on population that has that it will come back to us that was was in the
1990 capital projects fund for last year in order to support the general fund we moved that out of
that fund into the general fund it can be used for any any type of expenditure within the city
so general fund transfers just want to point these out these are kind of going out for our cities
so for public transit and community development to match their their funds and their spending
for the grants this year it's proposed at four million and and 1.1 million for community development
ema is a little bit akin to that ema is supported by multiple different entities
for for this area for the city this year it's um its transfer is at 373
thousand the orion amphitheater so this is kind of a good news stories with the restructure that was
done back in the summer of this year we were able to restructure that and this year we should not
have to transfer anything to the orion amphitheater in support of the operations out there
the gas tax funds that's the street lighting subsidy that i mentioned a few minutes ago
and then the post-retirement health trust so um so our retirees um there it's the cost of servicing
those um those retirees for medicate for medical expenditures is above the premiums that are paid
every year so it's actually valued at around five five to five point five million but because of
some of the savings in our normal health care for employees and and their premiums we were able to
transfer that they are co-dependent on one another even though we keep them separate in different
funds because of the trust the setup but they are co-dependent on one another so we feel it's
appropriate to to have those transfers go back and forth but this is helpful to the general fund
in alleviating some of the the cost to the general fund
so on the expenditure side flipping sides so this is the general fund department pie it is very busy
as always it represents all the departments contained in the general fund full cost for
the general fund to the departments is that 327 almost 328 million there at the bottom it includes
a two percent cost of living uh raise and i want to point out police fire and landscape really
those are are the have the largest employee base of all their general fund departments and so they
make up a larger portion of different pies in this area this graphic is located on page 17 of
your budget book this brings us to personnel or what we call authorized strength this year it is
proposed that council authorized personnel in a total of 3379 positions which includes both
part-time and full-time staff it is an increase of 46 positions from our current state and i'm
fixing to go through those in just a minute these graphics are located in your budget book beginning
on page 22 the some of our i'm gonna i'm not gonna go through every single one of the ads
in ad deletes for this year but i will mention some of the larger ones
so police um has 13 is added 13 new positions 12 new sworn officer which includes a sergeant and
one digital forensic lab technician in fire there are five positions three of which are district
fire chiefs general services there are three we added an h vac technician and a facilities worker
along with a general service coordinator to their staff
parks and rec 12 new positions includes both part-time and full-time some of those
um there is eight new positions that are related to the sandra moon complex and then two positions
that are related to john hunt park as well as other park positions
this is an oddity that came up i thought i would point it out so last year legal said that they
needed to move some administration around and move some administrative
positions around in their staff they added five position last year they said they come back and
delete five positions they have done so in the year and so i wanted to point that out that we
try to hear to our word as as we move through different deletes and ads when we bring that to
the council's attention the public transit they added three positions a paratransit worker
dispatch and a manager for our second shifts we run a couple of shifts out of public transit so
that's important to keep everything staffed and then i wanted to mention this one um and
in support of the reorganization there's one position that's been added in administration
there's one position that's been added in administration there are some other positions
that will be moved around within the organization but um but all salary cost is budgeted with um
in mention of the of the reorganization that'll be presented a little bit later
um
so every year we go through this in vacant positions i wanted to mention this while we
approve a total of full-time and part-time positions at over 3 000 um we have about a
fifth of those positions that are usually vacant and so i wanted to bring this up as um as we
turn over that we actually budget for that we don't want when we're looking at the general fund
it's such a tight budget we don't want these vacant positions to just sit there revolving around in
our personnel we want to use utilize those funds for other things in our general fund that that
they need to be allocated towards so um given that um we have reduced that we reduce the cost in in
a number of departments according to their vacancy count we also anytime we add positions
we only budget for half of their year unless we're told otherwise um and um and and then we
budget mid-range for their cost that way again allocating time towards getting those positions
established and those and people inside recruitment time and things like that take take that area so
before i leave this section of a personal and strength i do want to mention that the new
public safety salary scales that are going to be mentioned that are going to be talked about a
little bit later in another presentation are considered in this budget and they are they
are allocated within the current budget that's in front of you
um
health benefits um the city is self-insured as i mentioned before that means that we cover all
medical costs for our covered employees and their beneficiaries any cost over premiums and co-pays
up to 250 000 per individual each year for fy26 to date we cover 6,078 individuals and the projected
cost of premiums are set through our studies along with what we are given by blue cross and
blue shield the forecast study notes that costs will rise by about seven percent or 3.7 million
in next year the fy27 includes um those that rise in cost um how and although the city bears the
majority of that we do ask our personnel and so we have um we are asking them to contribute as
well to a seven percent increase in the premium rates um for for our city employees that are
inside the health care system so and i want to bring this up because sometimes people get
um get kind of wrapped around oh well we're only getting a two percent increase in cola
but we have a seven percent rise in our insurance costs how does that how does that equate
so the average pay for city employees is around uh seventy five thousand dollars annually with
the two percent increase it's up there on screen about fifteen hundred dollars and um at if you
have a family with ppo plan for 26 pay periods that's a 250 increase and so your net increase
in pay over the year would be uh approximately 1200 dollars so um so not so when you're looking
at percentages it's not apples to apples so for our health care insurance um is provided to
current employees and retirees um qualified beneficiary and i just want to bring this up
because our active employees per the policy is supposed to be provided this at a 15 percent
of of the premium that's what they um they pay and then our retirees are supposed to pay 60 percent
of the retiree premium and um the city of huntsville huntsville bears all the remaining cost
when it's actually allocated out um the retirees pay about 49 percent of their premiums and the
employees pay about 14 percent of their premiums in addition to this the city runs um runs a wellness
uh has has uh reflects a wellness rate if this if if the employees choose to participate in that so
they can get a reduced rate on their premiums in addition we also have the medical clinic that um
that is free free of charge for those taking advantage of that offering for the city
so health care benefits uh the app for active employees up there you can see how much our
health care costs have grown over time and how much of that portion is borne by by the city itself
pensions so we covered health care now we're into pensions so this is kind of our history of
contribution rates for the city remember we have tier one and tier two employees although they
receive the same although they receive the same benefits at the end um of their tenure here
um the the there's some different rates that we that we have to pay because the employees pay a
different rate um depending on whether or not you're tier one or tier two
so for tier one employees this year um in the first in a number of years we were able to have
reduced rates in both both tiers um for to uh 16.3 3 and 14.8 percent
so as of august the end of august for this fiscal year the city of huntsville has contributed into
our pension plans 26 million with employee contributions at a little over 11 million
total employees that are enrolled in rsa is 2600 and um and then our contributions per employee
continues to rise but not as much as the previous year and we're still in the middle of the year
employee continues to rise but not as much as it has in recent years um it's just risen a little
bit over 68 and there's a lot of factors that play into that but this is something that we
watch in order to make sure that we're kind of staying in line
so this is for we're getting outside of the general fund and whitney is going to come up in
just a minute to present the outside agencies but i did want to mention our lodging tax
expenditures this is not a slide i usually put up we usually just kind of talk about the revenue
sources that are in lodging tax lodging tax is accounted for and this includes liquor is accounted
for in a separate fund and one of the things to help with the general fund this year was we
actually moved three agencies into the lodging tax expenditure fund they were able to bear that
cost so so arts council the community ballet and the um and the symphony um and sorry the historic
huntsville foundation were moved here as is appropriate this fund tends to house those
agencies um that are what we call kind of closely held and um and where we are actually the owners
of that piece of property um for some of this so we felt like it was appropriate to move those
agencies here as well so i'm going to let whitney come up and she is going to talk about our outside
agencies
um
good afternoon whitney gentry grants manager um so this is the version of the outside agencies
schedule that is in the budget book this is found um on pages 26 through 28 and just like we did
last year we have we have organized the agencies into different categories i think this kind of
helps to show the different um areas of the city that we are helping through appropriations
and so um something that comes up is agencies that are considered outside but that we have
ongoing contracts with and so i highlighted some here the food bank the uh the marshall space
flight center fantasy playhouse and then um land trust these that we have kind of ongoing contracts
with these are for capital projects and so they are not considered something that gets voted on
every year these are these are ongoing contracts that we have committed to
so then this year we actually have produced a separate book for the agencies uh this i think
makes it a little bit easier to refer to them throughout the year and then also during this
presentation so the first thing that you will see is the agencies listed alphabetically this helps
to just organize because in the book they are organized by category but this is them alphabetically
and then um we we always include a version of this for you all this is the process and
timeline for appropriations and the big thing i want to emphasize here is that this is the
this takes an entire year to do one round of funding agencies receive their applications in
march of every year and then where we are now in september and then throughout the year agencies
are responsible for submitting a six month and then a 12 month utilization report so
it's not just kind of what we do here today it does take an entire year to to help these agencies
with their funding so a new section in the books that that i'm going to show you in just a minute
it's going to show you a five-year funding history and in this section there are some
symbols that are going to to show how the city supports agencies in different ways because the
city does provide a lot of support for outside agencies even outside of the annual appropriations
that that will be determined so the first symbol is you all actually it's council so so this is this
indicates that funding has been provided through the the city council improvement funds the next
one indicates that the agency has a current contract for services that they do for us
next one indicates that the city has provided some capital support for the agency
this symbol indicates that the agency has been granted a sub award there's only two kinds of
grants that are mentioned in this book there's arpa which is coming now kind of to an end and
then also our opioid settlement sub awards that we offer this symbol indicates that the agency
receives either free or reduced rental rates through city properties and then the last one
indicates that they receive funding from our community development department
so then as you actually go into the actual book this example that i'm going to show you is the
huntsville museum of art found on page 11 i'm going to kind of just tell you what you're seeing
as you go through these the first is the category that the agency falls under so huntsville museum
of arts of course is the the arts culture and tourism category the next is the mission statement
so if you're not super familiar with the agency this kind of just gives you a starting point for
that and then the project goal the project goal is actually written by the agency itself during
the application process and so if you think about the appropriation as sort of a contract
that the city makes with the agency we give you money you provide services to the community
this is the goal of that sort of contract that we enter into with them
so this is the five-year funding history section that i just mentioned the first is a bar chart
that you should be kind of familiar with it's shown a couple years now this shows the history
of funding through the appropriation process that we've offered for the past five years
and then over here are the symbols so of course this one indicates council improvement funds
capital and that they the art museum was a recipient of an arpa grant and the last section
is the community impact again this is written by the agency during their application process
and this you know this is what we are going to hold them accountable to during the six months
and the 12 month utilization reports this is what they're saying that they're going to do
for the residents of huntsville and this is what we are going to ask them to report on
this graphic just shows the different categories and their relationship to kind of each other
and if you think about appropriations as a statement of values it really shows the amount
of you know funding that is allocated from taxpayers dollars back into the community to do
good work in these different areas so i'm not going to spend a ton of time on this but i want
to just give you a little bit of an overview of what the different categories kind of entail
arts culture and tourism they have a note on there of course that these are funded by the
lodging and liquor fund so these are outside the general fund the remaining categories are all
inside the general fund community connections are these agencies this year are addressing
items like isolation aging financial constraints that sort of thing the economic development and
workforce category this is really focused on district revitalization training the next
generation of workers improving access for those with differing abilities and expanding
investment opportunities the education and youth services categories these are agencies that allow
students to be well equipped and families to not feel the constraint as their children grow and
learn the health care category these agencies funded proposed to be funded this year are really
meeting people where they are in the community making sure that your income level does not
determine the quality of health care that you receive the housing housing and basic and basic
needs category with the rising cost of food utility and rental this is sort of helping people to
bridge the gap of those things so they offer utility assistance rental assistance also hygiene
services clothing services anything that is considered a basic need outside of health care
the legal services and advocacy category these these agencies are kind of giving a voice to the
most vulnerable in our in our community so they're addressing a wide variety of issues but this is
making sure that if you have legal services needs that that that your representation should not be
determined to correspond by your your income level the neighborhoods and green spaces category
this is helping people in our community to feel more connected to their own neighborhood but also
to the the myriad green spaces that we offer throughout the the the city and the last one this
encompasses the library so this is making sure that everyone across across the city has equitable
resources to knowledge to technology and other community sources
so this is this is how it is kind of broken out just in a pie form so most of these agencies of
course are indicated here come out of the general fund and then just lastly some kind of interesting
stats to kind of put this in perspective of maybe some years in the past this proposed budget includes
funding for 55 individual agencies that includes 12 new agencies that have never been funded
through the city appropriation process of these 55 agencies their total ask was a little over
20 million dollars and then this proposed budget includes funding of 14 million dollars that's
inclusive of both both sources of funding for that so before i kind of turn it back over to
penny i'm happy to answer any questions or address anything can we just hold on to those
till we come on through the presentation and then we'll come back okay thank you
okay and now we're gonna kind of wind down a little bit to the final section which is our
enterprise funds so we're going to look at these share for both our water pollution control and
our sanitation so just going back a little bit of graphic of that financial structure so for
they are housed in enterprise funds because they are specifically set up just like a business
both of these services that are provided in the city are charged to the residents that receive
those particular services and so those that charge is designed to cover the cost of providing that
service for both of these interest entities
so for sanitation this is a graphic it's actually in your in your budget book found on page 44
but it has and it has all kinds of other type of information along with for both sanitation and
for wpc but these are all the different routes that are contained they work from monday through
thursday obviously allowing for holidays at different points in time but then covering
throughout our city and and the route map is for the weekly residential routes throughout our city
oops sorry backwards this is the operational expense chart the personnel is in blue and
landfill charges are actually in kind of that teal color or aqua up up in your upper left hand
corner those are the bulk of of what goes through for this service personnel makes up a lot of that
oops sorry
customer counts are growing steady at around one to two percent charges for services will
increase as well especially as the service area expands i want to mention that there was a rate
increase effective in fy 25 which alleviated the use of local taxes and if for 26 from the general
fund the rate increase forecasted in this particular proposed budget should help with the local tax use
for for funds for trucks and heavy equipment that we pay out of our 1990 capital projects fund that
will be a start but it is not complete we continue to have spending out of that 1990 fund for
the trucks on large trucks and service in our sanitation department
the operational the other thing is because this this fund is not in constant deficit
it now allocates some there is some interest costs that is allocated to it each year which creates
in income and will again be used for said capital equipment that i just mentioned earlier
so it's starting to look more healthy as we move through these years
for water pollution control operates they operate six what wastewater treatment plants in the city
with the capacity that's indicated up there for the six plants the largest of the plants are spring
branch in the western area which we did an expansion to not too too long ago
construction for major repairs and expansions of fleet plants and collection system along with
the personnel make up the bulk of the operating expenditures for for for the wastewater treatment
in our city
so charges for services are growing steady at around three percent this year estimated at 58
million includes a rate increase for that proposed budget and all operating expenditures are expected
to be right at 52 million which includes operating expenditures of 27 million and capital
improvements at 19.3 million and this that bottom line of 5.6 million will go towards other larger
capital expenditures that are in the line the the line item for the 19.3 million really covers
repairs cost inevitable things that come up in running a system this large as they go through
the year this 5.6 goes to that future treatment and expansions regulations things like that that
happen within our system and that is that is the end so thank you for your time i know it's a lot
to take in we had a lot of ground to cover appreciate it and i'm not sure uh council president
where you kind of want to go from here i think at this point we will open it up for discussions
mayor battle you have any comments to add after this presentation council members the time is
yours to ask questions anybody want to start any questions mr clink
um
you had mentioned just a few minutes ago about rate increases or have they already been
incorporated they've already been incorporated and they were passed by council in the last few
years um we came before you with multiple year rate increases that way there wasn't coming back
and back and the plan could be set in place in order to do the needed um and needed expansions
and needed equipment um and other costs associated with those two funds
mr meredith i just want to say for the record that i'll ask my litany of questions at the
regular meeting when some action can actually be taken
um anybody else then i'll go ahead and ask what can you just review with us again regarding sales
tax um our loss this year you have two online sales tax there's something 47 million was a loss
i think i heard so our sales tax i'm sorry i gotta get back to it um
so sales tax is not at a loss this year well i'm the estimated loss to online sales to online sales
um so is 44 million 44 so this this number is is an estimated loss if those online sales
if those online sales could be would be at the rates that were proposed for the city of huntsville
within within our area that is allotted to within our area so while we make up around
uh four and a half to five percent of the cities of the state's population which is what our
allocation is based on um which is in construct in relationship to the rest of the cities those
467 cities um are we actually because we are a hub and a larger larger unit with industry
and commercial entities we actually make up between seven and eight percent of the state's
transactions and um and revenues that go on within the state and some would say that percentage is
even higher um but um but so taking that into effect and looking at this this is um this is
one of the ways that we can get back to um to an amount that we are missing out of our
out of our general fund should ssut never came into never come into play never be enacted
so the estimate is seven to eight percent of all of the yeah don't don't don't get don't get on the
on the percentages look at the numbers we look our loss this year is estimated for the for the
for fy 26 is estimated to be 44 million dollars and that is you can see those numbers those numbers
in red that year it increases every single year partially because we continue to buy online
that line chart at the bottom partially because um because we continue to grow as a city
and the transactions for the state of alabama continues to grow as well part of that construct
is also the fact that um that the alabama department of revenue sets those businesses
that are able to be within to live within and charge ssut as opposed to a local sales and use
tax rate and those numbers have gotten larger they have allowed more and more businesses to come
under that hat you said that an effort is being made to look at solutions at the state level it
does that solution include um capturing revenues at the point of purchase so if if a purchase is
made by someone in huntsville that that taxes the online sales tax associated with that stays in
huntsville yes that is part of the consideration that seems to make a whole lot more sense
glad we're pursuing that thank you and then there's been a lot of concern about pilots but it
doesn't look like pilots is decreasing it's just going to stay flat it's going to stay pretty flat
and we've adjusted for that yes was your your point regarding vacancies was interesting that
20 percent of the um the personnel the funded personnel positions are 20 percent so we have
adjusted this budget to we adjust our budget every year to look at historical um percentages as we go
through and see which which which are vacant and which are things which which uh so like for instance
the finance department we tend to have all of our our personnel numbers are filled but for um police
fire landscape i mean those those employee bases are so large and the populations um especially
for like landscape the population is a little more transient we see those numbers grow and swell um
parks and rec is the same way it'll swell in the summertime and and then get reduced um during the
rest of the year due to part-time labor and other things that are that are required um for the
services provided by that department so in hpd we've had trouble filling all of our funded
positions but we are adding 12 more um what's the thought process there so believe it or not the
actual percentage of vacancies tends to remain the same so if you take you know uh a 20 percent
or 15 percent of the total base um when we increase we tend to be able to pull in a few more you
wouldn't think it would work like that but it seems to so um so it's a good way it's a good place
should we be able to fill those and fill more um obviously we allocate for hopeful growth
and in those different areas um but but looking historically at the numbers that is what we budget
to and i see mr hamilton there eager to help us increase our learning so the other thing that
for both police and fire what about described is true both of them have uh essentially a portion
of their entry level force that's doubled up in authorizations by cadets so when a new when we
hire someone to come in to be a new firefighter or a new police officer they actually come in as a
as a cadet fire cadet or police cadet uh and so the the fire or police position that they will go
to once certified is sitting there vacant they actually are there as a cadet while they go through
their certification process when they become certified they move to that and the cadet position
goes vacant so you're almost always going to have somewhere from 30 to 50 positions that you've
authorized in both police and fire vacant because they're in one phase or another of the transition
that's just the way that works that's a that's a sizable chunk of your vacancies are just that
that transition between cadet and full-time position and so the additional 13 then brings
us up to the level where the staffing level for hpd took accommodate the growth of the city
so that we can provide public safety is that correct and that's something that we've if you
go back over the last 10 years we've we've sought to add a few positions each year so that that's an
incremental growth the recruiting process and the training process can keep up with that if we went
zero for a number of years then suddenly jumped to where we needed to be there's no way that the
academy could keep up with that process and that's that's a little bit more true for police than it
is for fire because fire tends to be incremental growth based on on fire stations now not 100
like this year we've asked to add some because just based on the geographic spread of the city
we need to kind of position our district chiefs a little bit differently and provide better coverage
and so three of those positions are actually new district chiefs but you know if we if we add an
additional fire station which there will be some in the future we're going to need to add we know
out west we're going to need to add fire stations we know at some point green mountain is going to
need a fire station so there's some that we know that are going to out that are out there and you'll
see that reflected in the capital plan those will you know you'll have to authorize an entire batch
of firefighters and drivers and captains to fill those stations and those will be you know those
more those kind of large incremental jumps but that's based on on a fire station thank you very
much i appreciate that and then whitney i just want to tell you thank you very much for the very
thorough way you have explained the grants process you and pennie and i had a meeting
a while back last i think last spring to talk about the process and it seems like every year
you've refined it and but this book is really helps us understand your thought process so
thank you for that thank you for reviewing all those grants i know it took forever and then
again i really like the report the six month and 12 month utilization reports i think those are very
helpful as well i want to ask something real quick mr little i just want to follow up on
dr robinson's comments about this s.u.t shortfall um in this is it uh so the question was if uh
somebody buys something on amazon or whatever in huntsville the tax comes back to huntsville i
forget there's a technical term destination or destination destination source yeah so does that
require action in montgomery to change that or is that something we can change so as issue t was an
act um that was passed by the legislature it is a state controlled tax so yes thank you madam yes
mr clint uh where uh where does elia lily fit into the revenue and expenditures that we have in the
budget i'm assuming there's going to be some construction and some activity during this
coming year that would generate some sales tax off of building supplies so elon lily um will and
i don't know if you want if you want to speak a little bit more to that
so councilman clint it's a it's a it's a good conversation to have that that project is a five
year construction we didn't really model any new revenue for fy 27 construction is estimated to
start summer of next year so what will be left in this budget year would be mainly site work moving
of earth materials not a lot of construction materials being bought i think you'll see that
as we get into the next year's budget okay thank you appreciate it yeah any other questions is
your opportunity to ask questions about budget all right then thank you thank you miss smith thank you
to your staff for the very thoughtful way you have prepared this presentation you've given us a lot
to think about and again we will consider um considered at the september 24th meeting and
council members if you have any proposed amendments for that 24th meeting please make sure you
meet with miss smith to talk about potential budget impacts uh so that we can take care of those
before we meet and make sure any amendments are given to us writing yes mr mered
um where is that stated in our bylaws or oh it's not stated in our bylaws i think it would just be
good practice that you're asking for but it's not something that has to happen yes and it is not
just a courtesy for the staff for the council but it is a courtesy for the staff as well
and also so that we can make sure that things move smoothly we will move on to item 1c is a
presentation by the administration concerning the proposed ordinance amending chapter 2 administration
article 7 departments department heads and other appointed officers of the code of ordinances
followed by inquiries discussion and input by city council with the mayor and administration
officials and mr hamilton will make the presentation good afternoon council members john hamilton city
administrator uh one of the items that uh is on your agenda for consideration at next week's
meeting is an amendment to our central organizational structure and specifically on
the personnel side to certain appointed positions that are authorized by by ordinance so what i want
to go through here with you is exactly what those changes are some of them are whole new positions
in other cases they're amendments and you know i'll start with kind of how we're organized now so
we can then go step by step into what the changes are one of the things i do want to note in is that
we are kind of in mid-stride of over time getting all of our departments and all of our appointed
officials actually codified in the code of ordinances so one of the things that have been
working with the legal department on is while every single one of these is authorized by city
council approved ordinance and every appointed position is such as that happens over the years
and as our city our municipal government has been organized by various ordinances over the decades
most of them well before any of you were on city council well actually some a lot of them since mr
clink's been on council with the other four many of them go back well before uh before your tenure
on city council uh what we find is one they're actually kind of hard to find uh and so while
they exist and they're all legal they're actually challenging for the staff and for the public to
find and understand exactly how their city government is organized and the code of ordinances
is intended to be a place where as a repository of those things that are intended to be of
significant permanence and easy for folks to find and so you've actually just in the last couple
years years approved a few batches of these where we are over time transitioning all those
authorizing documents for the departments into the court of ordinances where they're easy to find and
i'll kind of point out where we are in that process what this action is before you now would
will take us another step forward but we still owe you more of these over time to bring them in
little by little get the entire city organizational structure actually codified in the code of
ordinances so i'll start with how we are currently organized and functioning obviously starting with
with our elected officials and i will note that the intent here some of these boxes i go through
this org chart are individual positions and those should be fairly obvious to you like the mayor
some of them also are intended to recognize a department so for city council is itself a
department and that's already codified in the code of ordinances the mayor is obviously an
individual position assigned to an organizational box that you'll see here in a minute and a position
that i fill and then there's a number of departments that that work very closely directly
with the mayor so the administration department and i'll go into more detail on that side kind
of a catch-all organizational structure just for certain positions just for the admin and logistics
of of having personnel doing things and obviously the finance department legal department and the
clerk and each one of these organizations have at least one appointed position associated with them
typically the department head but there are a few cases where there's positions below the department
are also appointed and therefore would be codified in the code of ordinances if i've got a question
are these four do they answer to you are they under you or or is this a co-equal thing like
the mayor in the city council so there's a couple different ways to answer that question first off
you know as as the lines are designated there if if those lines went to me then they would be
reporting to me those lines don't go to me those lines go to the mayor so each of these
positions report directly to the mayor i'll go through kind of how the mayor has has designated
how the ordinance designates leadership and oversight roles to myself and to to the position
that mr davis fills and oversight over departments but ultimately the mayor by laws who points the
positions that are there so that that that question will be answered but as that is constructed right
there those those departments report directly to the mayor from a grade structure standpoint
you have myself the finance director the city attorney the city clerk and mr davis
are all of the same grade it's also two of our municipal judges but they kind of obviously fall
a little bit different category so from a grade structure standpoint we've all been assigned to
the same grade thank you and so you know the admin department is made up of the office of the
mayor communications office multicultural affairs office office of economic urban development
and then you see down there in the corner kind of the details of the key positions that are
assigned to the office of the mayor so i break that out one option because those are key positions
they each have appointed officials that that are in them or lead them but also it kind of gives you
a sense of the construct so the way we're organized is primarily around departments and departments
are then made up of divisions and so when you look at the budget when you see the the more detailed
structure of the budget each department gets a budget and then they are broken out by division
so the functional building blocks of those departments and so it's easiest in this particular
format to kind of see that for the admin department
and then there's three departments and these are also kind of grouped by functions so human
resources ids and general services that that i pride oversight to on behalf of the mayor
and those are three departments that obviously primarily are focused on supporting the other
departments kind of internal internal support to to the other departments
we have a position of director of public safety it has not been filled for for quite some time
but that position is still out there on the books and it's something that as we as we go into the
transition that the the mayor has recommended here a position at that level we think there's
some point in the future where it comes back it's not something that's being recommended right now
but structurally that position is still still sits out there and obviously that would have the
obviously that would have the three public safety departments underneath it
and then this group of departments and you notice the color code is is there on purpose
because those are departments that that i provide oversight to and each of those are
departments that are pretty that are externally focused and delivering services to our community
on a daily basis and then you have the director of economic urban development
and under under mr davis for the next two weeks unless we can convince him to pull his retirement
paperwork back you've got the planning department and i break out the three divisions there the
actual director of planning position is vacant but the three divisions that make up the planning
department are each led by managers that are actually appointed officials
and then community development inspections and natural resources
city engineering traffic engineering and water pollution control
pollution control each led by department heads that report to the director of urban development
and then of course the municipal court so that is how we are currently functioning and organized
i want to go into what is i might step in and say this is about the same organization that we had
in 1984 when i first came to council we had a city administrator was ralph gibson at that point
dallas fanning was the director of economic and urban development
and you know it's it is it is it's time tested it's done well for us but i think it's time for us to
move to a secondary system
so uh go into what is proposed so what i've done is left up here what is not changing with one
exception you see the the box in yellow uh the the ordinance that's in front of you does not
create the position of director of city services but as we build this out you'll see uh the the
concept that we believe we should transition to over the years and i don't know how many years
that is uh but over time is establishing positions or executive level leadership
over the groups of departments and all the like items together and so i wanted you to be aware of
that concept and again that's something that uh whenever whenever the mayor feels is the right
time to bring to you we would do that but i wanted to see you that you see that as a concept so you
understand kind of the thought process that's going into this would that person be responsible to you
uh i don't believe so no i think what would happen you know the dotted lines there because
those things are vacant so uh you know my expectation is that uh that would result in
a transition in the duties of city administrator you would have executive level leaders are
reporting directly to the mayor but right now essentially you have two vacancies that i'm i'm
filling as part of my duties that's that's what the dotted lines are intended to represent thank you
so still a director of economic urban development with the the four departments that are
particularly focused on development and planning of our of our urban development
and you see the yellow box that appears here in the admin departments is very similar to what you
did recently to to create the office of economic urban development that's basically a division so
that it can house the personnel associated with uh with that function and then an office of
infrastructure development that would house senior director of engineering that's a new position
and then the other immediate staff that that position would require to support them
required to support them and then that position would have responsibility over
the three departments particularly focused on constructing our horizontal infrastructure
of course no change to municipal court now the i said we're at mid-stride of getting uh getting
departments and positions actually codified into the code of ordinances where they appear that way
physically again every one of these departments is authorized by by an ordinance but not all of
them have been done in a way that actually gets them published in the code of ordinances and so
that's what we're working towards is getting that accomplished for every single one of these so
we uh we need to continue to uh to work through to get every one of those
departments with a green check box on it and i'll tell you some of you know what is also before you
some of them that are in there you're now doing uh amendments to is based on this proposal
so first is the change to the duties and then therefore the title of what is currently external
affairs officer adding some significant duties associated with industrial recruitment and
economic development assisting uh the director and so that uh that title change in duty change
uh to external affairs and industrial recruitment officer
second is multicultural affairs office now this is one uh you know it's important that we all
you know it's important that we all that we all continue to learn as we go along
if you go to the code of ordinances right now you'll see that office still has in the published form
the title of odi this council took action uh not too long ago by ordinance to change the title of
multicultural affairs office and so that is that is the governing ordinance what i discovered after
the fact uh and we're now wanting to correct is that the way we did that while it is a completely
legal ordinance and is absolutely the the law of our city right now it was not done in a way that
causes it to be published in the code of ordinances and so the actions before you essentially redoes
what you've already done but gets it so that it the code of ordinances is updated and reflected
correctly and you know based on us having kind of discovered what uh what happened there uh our
commitment to you is that we will continue to make sure that when we bring you changes to departments
and or appointed positions we'll do it in a way where they get into the code of ordinances so you
don't have to go searching around for all these different ordinances that may contradict each other
next is creation of or establishment of the office of infrastructure development
and with that the position of senior director of engineering
the action also amends some of the duties of the director of the common urban development and also
not reflected on the chart but there's a deputy director whose duties also then are aligned with
the changes occurring to uh to his boss and so both of those are are in in the code
we codify the city engineering department so it gets added into the code and also the community
development so making progress on getting more of our departments actually published in the code
of ordinances and like i say we'll continue to uh to do that as we go forward so those are
the things that uh they're in front of you in in this particular ordinance
so just a recap this is just a list of the actions that are in that
in that so an amendment to title and duties of external affairs officer amending the title of
multicultural affairs office and the title of multicultural affairs officer many of the duties
of the director and deputy director of urban development establishing the office of infrastructure
development in the position of senior director of engineering in codifying the city engineering
department in the position of city engineer and codifying the community development department
in the position of director of community development so that is a quick quick snapshot of
of what that ordinance reflects and i'm happy to take on any questions on this that you might have
questions council members mr meredith
i would like a copy of the slide back it's the one thing that well actually the next item we
don't have either but we don't have copies of this i like copies of this
and um i will have a bunch of questions about this next week but um
i'm troubled by the fact that this has already been rolled into the budget without any action
from the council and i'd like to know what the impact to the budget is if all of this is passed
by the council sure that's no problem one of the things you know kind of as i totally understand
your point about kind of the way the budget process works you know because there are oftentimes
multiple things that have to come to you as separate ordinances and they're all interrelated
and affect the budget just like the cola for example you know no matter what sequence you do
those ordinances you have to vote on them separately and so there's always some interplay
and so you're absolutely correct that you know there are there are multiple ordinances that are
on your agenda next week that all have some relation to the budget so yes every time that
we bring you a budget it has to make some assumptions about what you might do on other
other related actions clearly if you choose not to approve those things where you choose to not
approve this for example or or amend it in some way that's going to have some budget impact we
have to go back and bring an amendment to the budget to to account for that and there's
the next item on the agenda today is an even bigger example than this one has significant
impact on the budget and so we do have to make assumptions like that and so clearly we you know
staff are prepared to react to that so you all choose to amend or disapprove one of these things
Mr. if it's possible to get that information prior to the actual meeting i appreciate it
meaning the impact to the budget sure absolutely thank you sir
Mr. Kling did you have a question personally uh in the work i do uh i don't really care about
the the labor pains i just want to see the baby uh people out in the neighborhoods uh they want
to see their streets resurfaced and uh finally it looks like useless is getting done so i think
for me i don't care how this is set up a position of mayor tommy battle or red spencer
whomever you know give them the tools let them do their job as they see most effective
we kind of cross a little bit into administrative i know we do we shouldn't but when we do
emails and stuff like that but uh it's a nice presentation but again it's what a mayor
this mayor feels like he needs to do the job the best way uh and probably 99 percent of people out
in the public they really don't know what the bar graph is or who does what they just want to see
the bottom result so yeah i mean i appreciate it but i'm very ambivalent ambivalent about all the
details however y'all want to set it up to make it work for you the best you know fine with me let
me know what the budget adjustments are and then you know that's that's the part that would come
into play and i would probably be you know amenable to giving the benefit of it out on
and it you know ultimately it's about span of control i mean just the basic human dynamics
of of managing and leading a large complex organization obviously we are a large city
and in rapidly growing city and so over time making sure that you're getting leaders positioned where
they need to to manage those issues deal with concerns in the neighborhoods of what those
things might be uh ultimately you've got to have uh you've got to have that structure in place so
that we can deal with stuff as a matter of routine as opposed to everything being an emergency
other questions miss miss wanton yes if you don't mind i would like a copy of that proposed or a
chart to include the updated titles what their responsibilities will be and if there will be a
pay raise involved with those positions sure i think that's what mr meredith was asking for as
well if you can provide to everybody well i was re-interranging i was specific because i said
i want to know if they get a raise thank you miss what can mr little any questions thank you
mr hamilton and mayor battle for for creating this organization i think one of the questions
we get a lot is how is the city accommodating growth and we don't think of the staffing that's
required so this is addressing as the city grows we're creating a structure to accommodate growth
as well thank you we will then move on to item 1d item 1d is a presentation by the administration
concerning the proposed ordinance amending ordinance number 89-79 classification and salary
plan ordinance for the addition of a public safety salary schedule to provide any rates for
certified law enforcement and fire suppression positions followed by increased discussion input
by city council with the mayor and administration officials mr hamilton
so the item that's before you is a proposal to make a pretty substantial amendment to the city's
salary schedule that that governs how we compensate employees and i want to say this is this is a
little bit of a long presentation and i'm purposely building it kind of block by block because
and this is i know as council members you're you're familiar with our pay chart there's
probably a lot of details that are that when we get down to the weeds on that aren't things
that typically you have to deal with but for the public in particular there's a lot of a lot of
folks probably in the public that don't really understand how it is that we compensate our
employees and ultimately it's it's their taxes that are funding this and so i'm going to purposely
go kind of step by step what i would ask i you know i understand that you typically like to hold
questions to the end because of the complexity if i'm on a slide where where there's something
about that particular slide it's confusing and i need to to clarify that please do that because
the way i build this it'll be really painful to try and go back this is uh this is a lot of
animations to kind of build this block by block so that it's understandable to everybody who might
be watching this so council members ask your questions as we go through yeah so one of the
things just for all of our employees uh they every position is assigned a grade there's a
process in hr where they go through based on the responsibilities and duties and qualification
requirements and they're assigned a grade and it goes from grade one all the way up to grade 24
and then their actual compensation within that grade is determined by a step process
and so it's built around the idea that a brand new employee would come in at step one and then
there's a step in a raise associated with step increase all the way out to step 25 that's the
that's the the theory under which it's built the reality is there are some positions and sometimes
in a hiring environment where we might bring folks in at what we call higher than minimum and so there
are some employees that might come in not starting at step one they might start at step five or ten
or whatever and in this particular case we're talking specifically about our certified police
and fire suppression personnel and that's true for them when they come in brand new they do not come
in at step one and so i'll explain that but ultimately that that step progression is uh is
what we're looking at here and then ultimately when when an employee gets to that top step to stop
to 25 we refer to it as being topped out and i know i know y'all have all heard that before
we have a lot of employees across departments that are in that topped out situation and for them
they don't as long as they stay at that same position that same grade they don't get any
more step increases for for the remainder of their career they do obviously get whatever cola
that it might be approved at each budget cycle so so with that to start so first off what we did was
just do an assessment of our region looking at similarly positioned cities and departments and
counties to to see how they are compensating their personnel in these categories that we're
talking about here and what we found in general obviously there's departments are kind of all
over the map but we understand where you know who are the departments that we're competing with for
talent and looking at how they're recruiting as compared to how we're recruiting and things
what we found is in general our entry level and early career salaries are actually pretty
competitive with those other departments mid-career salary advancement the way ours is structured as
compared to some of them there are a number of examples where it kind of as as our employees
are approaching mid-career they're actually falling behind relative to to some of those so
what i'll call competitors they're obviously our partners and friends but we also are competing for
talent with them and then the top out salary was actually well below a number of our competitor
our competitor partners
so the positions affected by what i'm going to present are all of the positions
that are held by certified fire suppression personnel or certified law enforcement personnel
the numbers that you see there are the grades within that grading system so a brand new firefighter
cadet and then firefighters at grade 13 police officer 14 all the way up to the deputy chiefs
at grade 20 the obviously both of our chiefs are appointed officials they are not in any way
included in this this is solely merit employees and you see the titles of the positions that
reach those grades and so obviously it's a mixture of both police and fire personnel
so what does this do it creates a whole new grade designation for each position so a 13
becomes a 13p and that matters just inside of our payroll system the way the program works
you know every position and actually if you went into the computer system you'd see that it's
actually a 013 or a 014 so it's a three digit code in the system that that governs the payroll and
manage the payroll so we needed a three digit code and so we went with p for public safety so a 13
becomes a 13p 14 becomes a 14p and on on so on all the way down to the 20s
it does continue to align our current the current salary associated with each step to a commiserate
step within the new grade and i'll show you that that's where that's where the same can get a
little bit confusing it does extend in that by by doing that it allows us to compress the early
steps which leaves room at the end to actually do an extension out to the full 25 steps and that's
how you ultimately get to a higher top out number it does accelerate the step-based salary raises
in mid-career so there's a couple places where you see these at the entry level these employees
would take what is effectively a two-step increase and then it provides that higher top out salary
what it does not do it does not in any way alter the relative grade level of any position
doesn't alter any of the hr processes for determining a grade level it doesn't alter
any of our hiring standards or processes doesn't change any of the job description or job specs
this is purely a payroll action that you're taking so you know when we talk about if if one
of the chiefs needed to create a new position and he went through the process of a jiq and took it
to hr and they went ran through the same process they do for any employee in the city this doesn't
any way changing those processes and that grade will be determined by by those hr processes and
they would be assigned though to one of these public safety grades based on that based on that
process so starting with firefighters and what you'll see i'm going to build this out to show
you how firefighters are currently compensated the structure to what i'm showing you here for
the grade 13 firefighters is the same structure as the grade 14 police officers but i will show
you that as well but you'll see when i get to police officers you're going to see basically
a repeat but you can see that they're they're handled consistently so across the top i know
those are small numbers i don't really intend for you to read them on that just reflects the
city's grade 13 step one through 25 the second line i've just kind of blown out steps one through
15 so it's a little bit bigger so it's easier for you to see so when we go bring in a firefighter
cadet they come in at step eight so this is an example of of a position that starts at higher
than minimum this was actually established by ordinance a few years ago we brought you this
action and and the things that are about to be reflected here because it's the the firefighter
and police entry level position is very unique as compared to all other employees in the city
so they come in at a step eight so steps one through seven are not part of the equation for
firefighters at all they start at step eight and they remain in step eight until they're certified
it's approximately nine months and when they get certified when they've completed their training
uh they skip over steps nine ten eleven and go directly to step twelve so they so they sit at
step eight for approximately nine months of their of their first year uh and then jump to step 12
once they're certified if there's if there was an issue with a particular individual where something
delayed their certification process they don't get to make the make the jump until they're
actually certified but that's a fairly rare circumstance but in general all your all your
firefighters would jump to step 12 at about the nine month mark and then on their one year
interval i'm sorry if i can interject if it's a lateral do they come in at this step 12
they do not so laterals and that and actually uh we just did some recent updates with you
and and and the way it is today i'm about to say how it is today because of this you know assuming
y'all prove this change will also need to amend this to keep the laterals where they need to be
so uh by ordinance laterals that are coming in with certain creditable prior years of service
come in at higher steps based on those years of service so if we get a lateral transfer
that has three years of prior service they come in at a step that well basically what we did is
if you came to us as a brand new rookie what step would you be at after three years and a lateral
comes in with three years is one step behind that so we are giving a little bit of extra credit for
having spent your career with us versus having come from somewhere else but we do need to
compensate them for that prior experience so they we don't feel like they should come in at brand
new entry level they are we did hire them because of their experience but we didn't want laterals to
be able to come in and jump ahead of the folks that have spent their entire career with us so as
you go through all the years of the potential years of service up the scale they're always one step
behind where they would have been if they'd been here for their entire time now with when you see
how we're restructuring this we've got to go in and amend those steps because it's going to be
different step designations with this change would they ever catch up meaning if they stay here for
the rest of their careers will they always be a step behind someone that started so they will
catch up at top out okay now here's the other thing is you get your step increase on your
anniversary so there are times where you know someone who is one step behind their anniversary
comes a little bit earlier and so they get equal and then a few months later that person jumps back
ahead so sometimes it might be less than a 12 month just based on anniversary and that plays
in actually at the end of this i'm going to give i've got four examples of actual employees of how
these changes affect them because you've got the cola and this change and their step increase are
all things that affect that individual's pay and so i kind of show you how that happens
and the step is specific to your anniversary thank you sir sure and so on their one year
anniversary they jump up to step 13 and then it's one step at a time as they go through
and so this if you so what i've done on this third line is just take this is the current grade
and just gotten rid of the steps that a firefighter never sits at to just kind of
compress it make it easier to read so what happens is they start at eight then jump to 12
then go to 13 and in sequence out to 25 and they currently when they hit their 13th anniversary
is when they get topped out so if you think you know the our retirement system basically lays out
a 25 year career path clearly we have lots of great great folks that choose to go beyond 25 years
but if you're doing a 25 year career you will have spent the last 12 years of your career topped out
and so that's the first step and then the second step is to go to the police
now going to police exact same format and structure here and so i'll go through a little
bit quicker because it's it's literally the same thing they come in at step eight they they also
spend about nine months going through the certification process they also jump over those
steps to step 12 and then on their first anniversary go to step 13 and so exact same structure to theirs
what the difference in salary because it's different grade so it's different different scope of
responsibilities so the firefighter the same grade but i noticed like they're different grades
they're different grades well the grade fighters that were eight i believe were 57 that's the step
okay let me go back you're using 14s versus 13s is that because that's their grades gotcha okay
thank you
so the structure to their progression is the same the salaries are different because the higher
grade now so a firefighter is a 13 when they get promoted a fire driver then they go to 14 okay
thank you and i'll the the promotional process also plays into this and i'll get to that here
a little bit later in the presentation so what you see across the top there is you know again
i'm gonna blow this up where it's readable i just want to kind of you can always kind of refer back
to the comparison what you see in the green is the the existing 13 now firefighters not the
only employees in the city that are grade 13 so we have teams we have employees all over many
departments that are are graded at grade 13 those employees are in no way affected by this and so
what you see on that top line is would remain the salary schedule for any non-fire suppression
employee that's a that's grade 13 and so if with your approval the firefighters would move to 13p
and that's the second line that you see there and i'll explain how we structured those salaries
to keep it linked in its in its structure to the existing 13 so this is what again going back to
the 13 with getting rid of the steps that that firefighters don't experience so they really
start at step eight jump to 12 and 13 and beyond and so after one year anniversary i'm just going
to kind of show how they progress based on their anniversaries here and so as you see 13th anniversary
they jump to to a step 25 so when you align 13p with that you see that at the entry level and we
said you know our analysis indicated that that that entry level in those early years the salaries
were pretty competitive and so what this proposes is keeping those lined up as they are
and so the first year and you'll notice that all the way out right until right before they hit their
sixth anniversary the salaries are the same but getting at the issue we indicated of we're
falling behind as they're approaching their mid-career point we wanted to do some compression to
accelerate them through some of these steps as they get into their mid-career points
so we deleted what what equates to the current step 18 and so what would be step 19 so if i'm
right now today i'm a step 17 on my sixth anniversary i jumped to step 18 with that
salary you see there are 69 000 and change so what we're doing you know if i'm on the 13p i'm a 7
and rather than going to a step 8 at the salary associated with step 18 the old step 18
i'm actually jumping to a salary that equates to the current step 19 right so it's that relative
to our existing numbers that equates to a two-step increase on my sixth anniversary
and then one a one-step increase as it lines up now and then a second compression where at my
ninth anniversary typically i would be going from the 71 500 to the 72 600 but we are deleting that
and another two-step increase so we are accelerating their progression through
through the salary structure
and then it carries out so what does that mean the current top out step 25 is what i get to at
my 13th anniversary 77 100 and again these are using 2026 numbers and and i'll you know obviously
we we have recommended that you approve a cola so these numbers in 27 become different but i'm just
to do an apples apples comparison for you structurally we're sticking with all the 27 26
numbers and so right now i would get to to that number at my 13th anniversary and now you get
there at your 11th anniversary so you're getting to what is currently the top out salary two years
faster than today and then as you see there's additional progression beyond that so they
continue to get step increases deeper into their career and so there you see the rest of the
proposed 13p salary structure so you'd be getting to step 16 in your 14th year and then you get to
your top out of your 23rd year so again what this does is using 25 as a 25 years as a baseline career
you're getting to the top out prior to your retirement eligibility and so you spend your last
last two or three years at that highest salary again all of these numbers get bigger
every year that that you're able to approve a cola so again this is just the fy26 numbers
mr hamilton sure if you know off the top of your head this one i'll give you grace on
what would be the top out the way it is now the way it is right now the top out is at 77,126
okay so this is significant and you had mentioned the middle and the top outs we were
less competitive and woefully less competitive on the top out where are our contemporaries
that you've based the fact that we aren't competitive where are they on these various
steps and grades so that that's an extremely difficult question to answer because every
single one of them is a little bit different on average to the best but on average the the
numbers that we picked here is that we set as a top out was not random it put us right in the
in the competitive range that we needed to be the one example that i'm immediately remembering was
actually aligned with assigned to the or associated with the police and it was actually
limestone county sheriff's department and you know as we were going through lots of different
permutations and stuff and looking at lots of different departments you know the mayor's
comment was i can't be below limestone county sheriff's department as it relates to police
now what we did ultimately is you know structurally made sure that everybody was treated the same
across across these two grades and so that's why when i go to the police when you're going to see
the exact same structure here it's another repeat but that was just one example i remember
we looked at a lot other departments and there there's a lot more departments to do comparison
against in law enforcement there is in fire because you have so many there's so many areas
around us are actually covered by volunteer fire department so there's not quite as many data points
much easier to get a real breadth of data points are on the police because you've got you know other
police departments you've got sheriff's department so things like that so there's just more departments
to compare against but ultimately what we wanted to do is make sure that we were consistent in the
way we structured it for both the fire department and the police department so so more or less
the average or meaning mean of the our competitors or would this be a bump of say one standard
deviation above to entice them to come to us so uh you know there's a lot of things that we're
doing that we we think uh helps with recruitment and in the way in which we uh we compensate this
is all you're seeing here is just their base pay for example all right so that's the other thing is
you know any anytime we will just you want the cola even if you didn't approve any of this if
you approve the two percent cola you know that makes this base pay number go up by two percent
it also means that any overtime they earn has gone up by two percent it also means that any special
assignments pay that both police and fire have quite a few positions that receive a special
assignment pay on top of this that goes up by two percent right and so and their benefits packages
the cost of that thing so it's it it cascades through a number of different things in the budget
for simplicity i'm just showing you the base pay which all of those things are basically built off
of the base pay so you know both chiefs have looked at ways in which they can offer some of
those kinds of things and other benefits and so that's that's a whole separate conversation a
great conversation to have but uh we believe that as we looked across you know one is we don't think
we need to go generate a wage war none of us will win that
all of our employees are worth a lot of money okay and but the taxpayers will only have to be
able to fund that so what this proposal is as we looked at you know what is a competitive wage
relative to existing and so this i think this keeps us consistent as opposed to jumping his head
now there's some departments that we're already ahead of but there's other departments we're behind
and so this is really trying to keep us consistent with those surrounding departments
this was not an attempt to jump way ahead of them because in some of those cases they have deeper
pockets than we do and they'll just jump back ahead again and we'll never we'll never win that
win that fight and so we we think that we should be consistent that's really what this does
in general it's not a dollar for dollar thing i'll never be able to get you down to the penny
but you know our assessment is this keeps us consistent with where we're seeing those kind
of highest wages and we do believe this is is competitive we would like to be able to do more
you know unfortunately what what the mayor's proposed is a very tight budget we would love
for it to not be so tight there's a number of things that we'd like to do more of and so you
the budget is built assuming that you approve this but but if if if there's a desire to amend
this and do more they will have to find that money that money does not currently exist
um so that's kind of where we are i think you had a long time to answer your question i think that
the simple answer your question is we believe this is consistent with some of the highest
highest compensated departments around us so it keeps us consistent with those with those peers
very good enough thank you very much miss hamlet
and police again this is going to be a repeat but i think it's valuable to show both
and so they go through the exact same structural progression as the the fire our fighters do
and we built out the the chart to match and so one of the things i do want to point out the intent
here on the way why we kept it aligned is because we we do have those consistent hr processes for
designating grades and we do have a lot of other great employees that are at these grades
and so the intent is that as we continue to do colas and other things other payroll actions in
the future that the step one of in this case 14p is always the same as step eight in the regular
grade 14 now just as council you know made the decision a few years ago to bring firefighters
and police officers in at step eight that could also that it could be something in the future that
we currently can't currently predict where you decide they need to come in at a higher step
obviously that'll be a separate conversation but in terms of building the the amounts of money in
each of those steps the intent is that it remains consistent with the current step progression
process as it relates to the existing salary schedule as we've always had but an amendment
to that in the future is a separate conversation that we need to address at that time but that's
what you know what you're asked to approve right now keeps that consistency between those two
salary schedules because they are as as we establish grades they are the same grade it's
a special designation based on their particular positions but it's still effectively a grade 13
a grade 14 15 16 on up okay and so then again the same same for police officers
now we do have grades 15 and 20 this is where i want to talk about the promotional process
because there is uh there's a similarity on how we propose this structure and a difference
between the things i just showed you i just showed you the two positions that are the entry level
positions for firefighter and a police officer and we do have a lot of great folks who choose to not
pursue promotion and decide to serve their entire career as a firefighter or entire career as a police
officer but also many that do pursue promotion the policy for all city employees when you get promoted
is whatever step you're currently at in your current grade so if i'm currently a step five
or a grade five step five whatever that amount of money is then i get promoted to a grade six
position i get i go to whatever step within grade six that gives me at least a five percent race
okay now just because of the way math works it's it's oftentimes you know 5.01 or 5.1 because we're
not going to you know put you somewhere in between you got to be in a step but whatever step gives
you at least a five percent raise per grade so the hypothetical i just gave you was someone going
from a grade five to a grade six many of our promotions are actually multiple grades many times
someone uh because we generally not always but generally have supervisors two grades above
the positions they lead you could have someone who's going from a position up to the supervisory
position and that typically would be a two grade increase in that case they get five percent per
grade so they'd actually get a 10 percent raise whatever step gives them at least a 10 percent
raise in that particular circumstance i've seen it's pretty rare but i've seen some that actually
have gotten a promotion it's three or four grades and so they would again be five percent per grade
whatever they're promoted and so for police and fire for the position talking about here
all of them that are at grade 15 or higher got there by way of promotion we don't bring in any
laterals in at any of those higher ranks or grades our laterals come in as firefighters or police
officers and so then they have to go through a promotional process so but we do need to hire the
salary structures to be set up ahead of the lower grades so there's actually an incentive to get
promoted right uh and so what we've done the similarity we did in proposing this new in this
case 15p and i'm showing you 15 i'll throw up all the other ones after they're all exactly the same
in terms of structurally how we did it so uh to focus your attention we took the existing 15
and started with eight went to 12 and then ran out all the other steps what we so we we did the the
starting steps the same way i did for firefighters and police what we did not do is those mid-grade
deletions all right so that's the difference between what we did for 15 through 20 as compared
to the 13 and 14 but you see the the early the early step compression and so
one through one through 15 aligned with the current eight through 25 and then the additional steps to
get to the higher top out out there at the end and then just to really make it confusing 16 through 20
they're all structured exactly the same so same thought process went into how each of those are
structured and what ends up happening when you you know sometimes you'll have a firefighter who
is highly motivated to get promoted and as soon as they're eligible they'll go compete to become a
driver and they'll get promoted and then as soon as they're eligible you know compete to become a
captain and so they will progress at a certain rate but because it's set up where it's five
percent from your current salary level that that brand new driver who's been with us only three or
four years total is going to be at one step another person could be promoted to driver the
exact same day but they'd already been with us for 10 years they're going to be much further down
the salary schedule at grade 13 so they will you know that those additional years of services
acknowledged as part of that promotional process and so they will jump to wherever gives them a
five percent raise at grade 14 and so there is not an attempt in our system does not attempt to say
every firefighter that goes to driver then starts driver at the same step they go relative to their
years of experience based on that five percent per grade promotional process and so you know where
folks may fall as they then go to captain or in the case of police officers going to investigator
or sergeant or going to lieutenant they all fall into these grades and on what step based on where
they where they came from in terms of what step they were at and based on that five percent per
grade promotion so that's that's how these ultimately get structured but gets them all out to
to that higher top out that we believe is competitive with with our surrounding peer agencies
so some examples and these are i've just picked four employees i'm not giving you the names not
even telling you which department but some of these are police and some of these firefighters
but just to give you an example so this first one is well you can tell that's a firefighter
because it's grade 13 this particular individual has five years of service so right now today
right now today he's a grade 13 step 17 making 68 000 so the the cola we propose and obviously
this chart assumes that you approve approve the cola which takes effect in early october
would get the two percent two percent raise and so it's still a grade 13 step 17 but goes to 69 400
then what's proposed here is to take effect in november now the reason for that is what we've
described here actually getting it built into the system and getting implemented is an enormous
amount of work for the payroll division they can't they can't do it ahead of time because
that'd be pretty presumptuous we got to we got to do it the way you actually approve it
and so what what we've done here is first everybody gets the cola and then this can be go live in
november having based on rebuilt the whole salary schedule and every individual has to be assigned
to a particular step based on their situation that is mandated by the ordinance and so in this
particular case this employee would go from a 13 17 to a 13 p 7 as we said those early years this
this employee is at five years it was lined up the same but then in december this particular
employee hits his hits his anniversary and so would go to step eight and would jump up to
71 800 so between now and you know to january i kind of picked a block there it's about a six percent raise
here's an example of a grade 14 very you know but 21 more than 21 years of service
so currently is a grade 14 step 25 so you know has been topped out for for a number of years
would get the two percent cola in october and november adjustment would go to a 14 p 17 and then
he hits his april anniversary and that that final block it should say today through april a seven
percent raise here's an example of an employee's a grade 16 with 12 years of service you can see
there he's a 16 18 remains that but with two percent cola then goes to a 16 p 8 which which
does not represent a raise but then goes at his february step increase up another level to a four
percent raise and then an employee that's grade 18 with more than 21 years of service and you can
see the progression there obviously i failed to update that final block as i copied this format
down but they each get those raises based on their steps and here's the thing this is
i've got the number here how many employees this affects
it's 863 employees that are affected so you can imagine the very large plurality of different
anniversaries we have amongst 863 employees between the two departments and so every single
one of those will be affected differently depending on when their step increase hits relative to
colas and other things but these were four examples kind of give you a sense
one is to emphasize what i showed you before was purely to so you understand the structure using
the 26 numbers when this actually takes effect in november with your approval they will all have
already gotten a cola so those numbers become a little bit different because of the cola and then
of course they continue to get their step increases in some cases many of these many of these employees
are topped out so they'll be back to getting step increases for the first time in in many years so
i'm happy to take on any questions that you have that is a lot to absorb council members what
questions do you have mr i want to go back to the big chart with all the steps just for a little
clarity on my part so we'll just use 15 so somebody that's
um so somebody that's
step grade 15 step 20 today there'll be if this is all approved it'll be
it'll be a wait i need to use the 25 i had the question then i didn't want to interrupt you
even though you told us to interrupt you that's right having a brain part all right so first of
me make sure if you if you look at the ordinance um one of the issues that we wanted to address
is that because right now these employees get topped out so early you could have a broad range
of years of service where every where where all those employees are currently topped out so you
top out of your 13th year so we could have an employee that's been with us 13 and a half years
and he's topped out versus someone who's been here 30 years and you know she's making the exact same
salary because they're all once you get that's part of the issue with the top out is when you
get to top out that's where you sit for however many years you choose to serve after that so
i mean you literally could have somebody who 13 years of service versus somebody 35 or 40 years
of service all sitting there the same thing so what we what we did is to try and acknowledge
at least some of that difference in the proposal is if you are currently a step 25 but less than
18 years of service you go to a step if you're between 18 and 21 you go to a next higher step
and if you're above 21 you go to the next higher step after that so in your hypothetical if i'm
at a 25 what step do i go to it depends on how many years of service you have there is
a little bit of spreading out of those employees now we acknowledge that is that is not
a full acknowledgement of everybody's individual years of service
you know there's there's some there's some folks if you tried to do that they just go right back
to being topped out now they you know they obviously appreciate the rage but some of
this is also about how do i balance affordability how do i incentivize continued service and so
that's kind of the structure we came to that was that could acknowledge it as best we could and
remain affordable so that's that's where we are so if you use a hypothetical if somebody's step 25
there's three potential answers to your question based on their years of service okay thank you
i think i'm good thank you other questions i'll ask one then so going back to this
um with regard to increasing the years to top out
it would seem that sometimes the focus is on the steps rather than the salary and it almost seems
to me like if you just focus on steps it's going to take me so much longer to top out instead of
looking at how much more money you will be earning how much more capacity you have to earn in that
time that's that's that that's where the incentive for retention is it is i mean so it's certainly
for for those and one of the things i mean i spend a lot of time talking to employees and managers
about you know their their you know their own decisions on when to retire i will every one of
us will go through that same decision making process and when's the right time for us to
retire given our personal circumstances some people are motivated by higher salary and understanding
how that impacts their pension because we're in a defined benefit plan for on the pension plan and
so you know your salary has a direct impact on what your pension benefit is as well as how long
you serve so you know our employees increase their pension benefit by higher salary and more
months of service okay both of those things have a direct impact in that formula that determines
that right and some some people are in a situation you know whatever their whatever
their family situation is or their personal goals where that can be very very motivating
other people have made a different choice and some of them have said i'm serving 25 years and
that's it no matter what right and that's again that's their choice that's it that's their own
personal decision to make so we certainly for for employees that are seeking to to improve their
compensation and ultimately improve their pension then having additional steps to go that they
otherwise would not have had i would expect is pretty motivating for someone who's not at all
motivated by the money then then it's not going to affect their personal decision but again we've
got 893 employees impacted by this you got 893 different thought processes on on what this means
for their own personal situation but you're right i i would say i i've talked to employees and i'm
not you know this is across other departments as well that talk about being topped out and then
when you say okay well what's the actual compensation associated with that it
sometimes there are some folks who get they kind of get fixated on saying i'm at the highest level
you know in this particular case uh you know you immediately uh in this action jump folks higher
than they would ever have been under the existing structure so it is you know direct and immediate
improvement for them uh you know everyone i want to be compensated as well as they possibly can we
want to compensate them as well as we possibly can but it also is what actually fits in the budget
so having balancing balancing that is really what this is attempting to do it also looks to me like
since we will be paying those eight potentially paying those 893 employees more than we would have
under the current salary structure can we afford this if we run the numbers out into the
10 years from now and how does it impact the budget so we haven't necessarily modeled it all
the way out there because there's so many other variables i'm not sure that we could get to a
model that we would necessarily trust uh costs of employees is our our single largest cost always
has been and always will be uh and that's something that uh that any organization has got to keep their
eye on right uh and so yes absolutely every just the cola so you know we propose a two percent cola
across every single employee that that sets a new number that the next year's cola will be based on
and so it absolutely is it has a multiplicative effect across the years uh and uh and so those
are all things that we're going to have to be able to afford um the reality is this is one of those
things i'll tell you that you know i had a conversation with uh with both chiefs and
i've shared this with the mayor as well in in my opinion we can't afford to do this we can't afford
to not do this because the issue is we have got to ensure that our community is safe and you know
every single department does enormously important work if we had decided that the work of one of our
departments was unimportant we would have gotten rid of it right but it's all important but i think
as you all know in engaging with your constituents if people don't feel safe leaving their homes they
start worrying a whole lot less about the pothole in the street right they still worry about it but
if you feel unsafe that suddenly in terms of the hierarchy of needs getting that dealt with suddenly
becomes a whole lot less important we have got to ensure uh that our community continues to be safe
this is not because we're currently unsafe we need to get there we are a very safe community
this is about how we sustain that which obviously all of us have to work together to do that and we
think making sure that we're recruiting and retaining the right talent uh is the biggest
component of that obviously you know technologies help as well right so technology can make us more
efficient but ultimately this is the people business and we've got to make sure that we're
getting the right talent and retaining them as best we possibly can and we are in a very
competitive environment we do have departments around us uh that have been able to tap into
different sets of resources and do some significant escalations in their salaries
and they're recruiting our people away and so this is we are we are from a personnel standpoint
from a talent standpoint in a very competitive environment and so trying to remain competitive
given our size and scale which is challenging so you know one of the issues that we deal with
is a small department around us can come in and offer one of our people hey if you'll come over
here i'll give you five thousand dollars more well the only way for us to counter that out counteract
that is to get every single employee a five thousand dollar race right if we feel like we've
got to match them well it costs them five thousand dollars for that one recruit it costs us five
thousand dollars per person and so it's a much bigger number right and so we are in that
environment where where some of those other departments are able to do some things are
challenging so we've got to be prudent about how we we go through this but again i believe that
what we've represented here is competitive with those with those surrounding competitors for for
talent and again they're all to our partners we go fight fires together and fight crime together
but when it comes to recruiting people they are competitors so so so this this change is designed
to help us to recruit and retain and fill those vacant positions that we have and also to
accommodate the plans of a growing city so that we can provide the protection that we need yes
thank you anybody else um can i if i could just one one moment i realize um you know council
members you've got you've got a lot on your plate to consider in this budget cycle uh and i know
just having talked to i think just about all five of you there's different things that you're
thinking about and contemplating in terms of potential amendments or things that you might have
and this will now be my i don't know 14th or 15th budget cycle most most times in all those years
so in my experience and kind of working with y'all and sitting here watching you uh many of
the amendments you bring like inside the general fund you know we can figure it out the night of
you know i want to amend this and take 10,000 from here and add 10,000 over there or whatever
those are ones that that the finance department does have the ability to advise you during that
debate and then make those decisions and we can still have a good balanced budget uh i would say
even you know the the reorg uh has actually a relative to the size of our budget uh you'll see
that that has a pretty limited impact and if you if there's things about that that you want to change
then that's something that we could probably deal with in the heat of the moment if we aren't aware
of if we aren't aware of ahead of time this is extremely complex and you might have an idea to
i just want to make this little tweak and that might be a hundred thousand dollar tweak another
of you might have what you think is a similarly sized tweak but it's actually a million dollar
tweak we will not have the capacity the staff will not have the capacity to advise you on the
cost of that in the heat of the moment in the middle of council meeting so what i would recommend
to you obviously it's it's your choice i would recommend that if you are wanting to kind of
dig deeper into this and explore changes to it you're going to be best served by engaging with
myself and penny and her payroll staff to do that analysis for you i've had the payroll staff run me
some what-if scenarios on this and it's the time it takes to do that is measured in hours not in
minutes so if if it's something that you do want to engage and drill deeper into i will absolutely
be available on your schedule to go through it with you and and try and give you the answers
you'll need to make an informed decision it will be extremely challenging if not impossible to do
that in the middle of the council meeting so i i offer that to you as a recommendation
and again with regard to the professional courtesy we owe the staff please engage with
miss smith mr hamilton if you have questions or plan to make an amendment regarding the potential
budget impact mr emeritus did you have a question well commenting on that um if we had ran across
what you're saying where it was going to take hours instead of minutes to go through it this
body also has a right right to pass a continuing resolution to allow them time to
set that out and then we can at that point pass a budget so you don't have to technically pass a
budget next week so we do have as much time as this body would need for them to make their uh
their adjustments i think that would create significant challenges but you're right because
we have that doesn't mean you necessarily should do that i would suggest you have a week here to
work things out bring your best estimate of how things would work to the council meeting but
we do have that opportunity if we need it mr cling did you i would also just i was just going to
recommend on that point if i could um you're absolutely right that you know you technically
could do you could do a cr um i think the way because of the timing because this doesn't take
effect until november as it's currently as it's currently proposed if if we encountered that in
the middle of the meeting my recommendation then so i'll offer it now would be to go ahead and pass
the budget as is postpone this to the next meeting in october resolve that and then we could you could
come back and amend the budget to account for what you did in this you know in this particular
action and that that would not be an insurmountable issue administratively for for the staff obviously
not the preferred course of action but just in terms of the timing we have time to respond to
that to those changes if we needed to because of because this doesn't take immediately effect
and thank you for that option mr hamilton thank you mr cling did you have a comment
uh i think more of a question for our city attorney uh just so we don't get hit with a
whole bunch of amendments that other council members are presenting at the meeting itself
can without violating the sunshine act can council members who have proposed amendments
put them out for all five council members to see so at least we know what's coming
instead of last minute surprises right at the meeting itself i think you can do that but you
cannot deliberate on those things one way communication correct and again that would
simply be professional courtesy yeah i think that would make things a lot smoother if we know what's
coming and then we have a chance to individually think about it but yeah no deliberating okay
we have two more items on the agenda and again speaking of courtesy for us and for the audience
let's go ahead and take a 10 minute break if that's okay with everybody so we'll
we'll come back at 1 28
you
all right it is almost 128
and we're going to go ahead with the agenda one well we don't have to have quorum because
we're not going to be voting thank you 1e is a presentation of the proposed fiscal year 2027
update to the 2014 capital improvement plan by the administration followed by increased discussion
input by city council with the mayor and administration officials and is this this is not
going to be your last time at the dais i think the next council meeting will be no ma'am we still
we're just glad to see you here shane i'm glad to be here this is this one heck of a team good
afternoon council members i think we started with good morning we are now saying good afternoon but
a lot of progress has been made so i'm here to present to you the 2014 capital plan for fy 27
the project plan remains much the same as you've seen in recent years focuses on mainly four
really key categories being public road improvements economic development drainage and
bridges and public infrastructure that public infrastructure piece is more focused on
getting back into our neighborhoods and our established established corridors so we'll jump
into this so annual reoccurring revenue i believe this may have been if you're looking at some really
fine detail of miss miss projected revenues this this item along with the 90 plan was part of that
tax structure but it's 69 million 410 thousand dollars you will notice there's no planned debt
issued revenue so if we were going to issue debt service and go borrow money that revenue or that
issuance of debt we were going to borrow would jump up into this line to add to the annual
reoccurring the inner reoccurring i like to call it is cash that comes annually into the budget no
no debt proceeds or any grants associated with road projects those are captured in a different manner
the there is a topo there fy 26 capital should say fy 27 i'll have that fixed for you next
thursday but the proposed projects is 64.3 million dollars our current annual debt service within the
plan so prior debt services for roads and other infrastructure that you have approved
currently sets at 9.4 million so a total expenditures of 73.73 million dollars
now certainly 73.3 is more than 69.4 but remember both capital plans when mr hamlin comes up with
199 plan these are dedicated funding sources so those carryover balances roll forward to the next
year it's a rolling tenure capital plan so the current balance sets just over 5.6 million dollars
so when you add that to the plan revenue it leaves an ending balance of 1.3 million dollars to the
positive let's get into you see this every year is is how are we doing this this project plan was
typically when we passed it in 2014 was intended to carry some debt service to accelerate larger
projects and you know in infrastructure one of the first things we did in 2014 when this was
passed we did restore roads one and that was 125 million dollars from the city and 125 million
dollars from the state those five projects have grown into 11 and it has exceeded 250 million which
is a good thing for us we're we're getting more projects completed but at the inset we borrowed
50 million dollars right out of the gate to be able to go do restore roads so it's always
intended to carry some debt but predominantly be a cash as you go pay as you go fund so for the
fy-27 budget that ratio would be just under 13 percent debt service and just under 88 percent
cash for the projects that are to be completed so what does that look like in this 10-year plan
you can see that the debt service does jump up to just under 30 percent i do want to
uh go through that and tell you that is a little bit of an anomaly that is not the full you'll see
that number compress the 28.7 is really two prime both tiff 8 and tiff 9 so so as we borrow those
debt funds for tiff 8 and tiff 9 our capital plan has always paid those early debt services
till that private investment has occurred those revenues start coming in and then the tiff will
actually reimburse those so this is modeling tiff 8 and tiff 9 those that next five years after that
you'll see that 28.8 get more in line with that 10 to 12 percent is that i'm sorry is that kind of a
that 12 percent is that kind of just a standard we we have i've looked the last five years we've
been in that eight to ten percent range so yeah this has creeped up a little bit with the ryan
amphitheater and some things that we've done but it's usually about a 90-10 split you're welcome
so funding by categories we we take the 14 plan and it's and it's really in five categories six
if you add the the debt service now i think this really shows uh the tale of two of the of what
this capital plan is meant to do it's meant to turn the knob when we need to in this community
to accelerate capital plans or do tiffs where we can advance infrastructure so the the top category
is just the 2027 budget and what i mean by that is when we get to the red bar which is the debt
service so uh the predominant uh theme for fy27 will be the redevelopment efforts that's corridors
i think uh memorial parkway corridors north village retail project that we've done in recent
years it's been hayes farm it's been bob wallace where whole foods is those corridors it's been
mid city on university drive those well-established corridors were reinvesting
um and for this um the highlight i would refer to that's the the most highlighted project that's
going on right now is our mill creek project it is significant uh both in reward to the community
but also an investment if you may remember we received a 50 million dollar grant to go with that
uh and that project has eight phases and we'll go on for the next five or six years in this capital
plan so that's why you see that bar being uh the highest next exactly what this project this capital
plan is supposed to be and that's roads and bridges in orange then we get into our multimodal parking
and then next our annual debt service economic development has always been a small piece of this
it has been to really deploy infrastructure in the community
and then cash reserves we we want to be able to make adjustments if opportunities arise with a
grant project is to be able to match those grant proceeds so we always want to have some cash
reserve whether it be an industrial project opportunity like elia lily that we can respond to
or a federal grant program that allows us to take a long-awaited project for this community and be
able to go compete for that grant project so then let's jump down to the the bar to the bottom is
a tenure kind of rolling average if you will each year we'll fine tune this going forward based on
the needs of the community so you're only voting on as i've always said on the 2027 line item of
this tenure capital plan but as you can see as we balance back out going forward roads and bridges
remain keen at the top at 29 percent the debt service is a little bit of an anomaly at 29
percent as we move to the right in this plan that will be reduced as tif 8 and tif 9 start
paying the debt service independently of the 14 plan providing some supplement cash reserves you
can see are over 100 million dollars i don't want you to let that fool you or the public
what will happen those outer years as our engineering department planning department
identify road projects what are those next big road projects they will get put in those years
six seven and eight and you'll see that cash reserve look much more similar to the fy 27 budget
it's just saying there is cash there in the outer years to do significant projects there's been talks
of you know that restore roads too to do something like extend the interstate or i-565 memorial park
how do we accelerate those that gold bar there showing you we have that ability to go try as we
get new leadership montgomery try to go make that happen this plan is very flexible in the way it's
been designed in the way we have used and then good stewards of the taxpayers money in my opinion
redevelopment efforts that's annually at about 10 where we're taking corridors we're reinvesting
into existing parts this is a growing community and we're spending infrastructure in the growing
parts of our city but we this plan also goes and reinvest in the existing parts of this community
we don't even want to feel left out when we're talking about infrastructure sets at about 12
percent and the multimodal and parking downtown continues to grow so we've you know our western
corridor with aryan we've got parking coming there multimodal is our greenway networks throughout
all districts sets it just under 10 percent and the economic development count has averaged
anywhere about five to only seven percent of the overall revenue spent how this it's this is an
infrastructure capital plan so i'm almost finished to ask any for you to ask any questions and
any requests you may have i always give you this overview of what does 27 look like
47 active and future transportation projects totaling over a half a billion dollars
27 projects you're looking at northern bypass phase two that's from memorial parkway to winchester
road improvements to help morning and afternoon rush hour on governor's drive there around the
california intersection homes avenue from downtown into research park eastern bypass
winchester road construction the last phase of that widening project
we'll start swan cot road design get a head start on that as we start to consider what we'll do with
hopefully tif-8 and tif-8 would actually provide accelerated funding for that construction phase
one a resolute way the most important project to redstone arsenal and certainly to our commuters
both locally and abroad getting in and off post the one of the first two phases into
the new road in south huntsville the edinburgh extension obikove road we have started design
this adds continual funding for obikove road widening in the hapton cove community to start
looking at right away and and the construction of that is actually funded within this 10-year
capital plan and then our county line road relocation future key projects i think are
important for our community and ones that are in particular asked about by our citizens is resolute
way phase two that's actual interchange piece that would connect governor's west over i-565
in madison boulevard the east arsenal connector that will actually be part of the first phase of
the southern bypass for the city in the future phase three or the last phase of the northern
bypass which would get state route 255 from winchester road us 72 that would complete that
loop from us 72 on the east side of the city to i-565 there on research park boulevard would be
one half of councilman clings ring road that he keeps putting we'd be 50 complete with that
and then probably two most critical projects left in this city to really push the needle on and
that's interstate i-565 extension east of sheldes road and the interchange of i-565 us 231 in our
downtown corridor interstate i-565 exit three upgrades we do have some design funds in the
capital plan it's not enough but should you and limestone county move forward tiff eight we would
take that off the list out of this capital plan and let the tiff district accelerate that
drainage improvements is pin hook creek flood mitigation broadland branch improvements those
are active ongoing projects have multi-years of funding within this capital plan corridor
redevelopments as i mentioned the mill creek choice neighborhood project in partnership with
honspill housing authority there along governor's drive and clinton avenue avenue certainly our
downtown business district we're there's an ongoing annual what we call downtown redevelopment
fund that that gets seeded every year and as a big project comes we complete that project and move
on to the next downtown project the park project that is currently active so we are in phase one
of that if you've been long hard of hunts where you start seeing some of the stacked stone going
up vertically and we'll start to see more and more activity as we get into the fall our engineer
department should be early next year bidding out the five bridges and then we'll get into the
landscape bidding probably late next year calendar late 2027 and then certainly our north parkway
retail corridor north hunswell village good news to the city council we closed last friday took all
day but we got closed with target and her developer so we got our money back for the and the project is
a green light i texted miss watkins and said congratulations there's no turning back now so
that that's the critical point when you can transfer that property you have a project
and then the university drive in south parkway corridors we continue to work with you know public
private partnerships if someone wants to acquire property and see it redeveloped or greenfield
sites along those corridors there's money in this plan for the future leaders that have open confidence
in and jim mcguffey and zach mcgovern to carry out there's funds in here for them to have success
we want we want this city continue before and then governors drive west as as we see that mill creek
redevelop there's a lot of opportunities been a lot of good through there you look at stove house
and some of the things but then the south side of governors on the west side of of that corridor has
great potential what happens to a new possible post office but we have put plans in there for that
uh economic development efforts elia lily of course largest investment in the state will kick
off next year it'll take about five years to complete cummings research park we can see growth
there but also need so this plan has needs to keep the park and what it's known for is one of the
best research parks in the nation we have to reinvest in that our vbc expansion you you were
very gracious to approve that tiff district and we'll get started with that next year north and
west huntsville industrial development there are plans to continue to grow the north huntsville
industrial uh development park it's uh not quite full but it is near there we we have plans that
could allow us to add new acres to that to bring a new industrial park offerings one of the things
that we are lacking if you look at chase industrial park north huntsville industrial park and some
others um they're pretty much full we've had good success so i know our team is looking at how do we
go create some new industrial parks we think that it will be north and will be west and
and we're really looking at that but this plan can help handle moving that forward county line
road retail corridor food city is is under construction finally and going really well
at the corner of oh at the corner of oh 20 and county line road but there's conversation going
what phase two looks like along that corridor and having good conversations certainly with the
school kicking off exit three on the south side we had a good town hall meeting last night there's
more retail opportunity coming to that that part of the city swan cot road residential and commercial
development is really picking up some steam out there we've put you know 16 000 jobs at that exit
and naturally with the school coming it's it's important for us to make the investment i think
that's what the tiff is for but will also help people commuting you know if if we can move
citizens to the area they work and not travel 20 miles and you can move 5 000 people off
op 65 and get them better where they're trying to go anyway it helps us if we live in south
huntsville or north huntsville or east side of the city or downtown so those investments you are
making out there will actually help our transportation network and then jetplac industrial
working barbie peak and i got a dear friend that announced his retirement at the airport
and sent him a text i think amy would do a great job leading their our airport but working with
them to see what that swan cot bowing road area looks like and being able to create future jobs
after that i'll answer any questions council members what questions do you have yes mr cling
so
it's a good question so you know we will start next year on phase two the northern bypass which
will get us to winchester road so you have that buck corn area i know it's in the county but that
area puts a lot of pressure on highway 72 at moorsville road 9565 getting that piece connected
will give residents both in the city and the county in the north what northeastern portion
an alternate route to work to still get to the west side of the city i think that will make a
huge huge impact there'll be one more phase of that it's in here gets you to highway 72 the east
arsenal connector is a piece that will actually help research park boulevard and that main gate
into the arsenal it gives actually space command and some others a different access into the
arsenal but if you go look at all that um the next 10 years i think everything would be complete
eastern bypass working with the county to u.s highway 72 east the only missing piece would be
thread the needle really through the southern portion of the city and that will be very
challenging it will be very expensive we have preserved the corridor but most of that will have
to be elevated and some cooperation through the arsenal we continue to have that through our mpo
everybody is in agreement to that alignment we've been on preserve the right away for that
but that would need that section will need more help than what this capital plan could
support and we do that through the mpo and hopefully some through some federal help and i
think separate from that there's already some preliminary engineering work going on for the
design for 565 at parkway interchange expansion yes so about about three years ago we this council
approved a contract there's a couple of million dollars so miss martin and i led some outside
consultants with three alternates of what that project should look like and sat down with martin
bartlett federal highway authority and aldot and went through multiple iterations and we got it down
to two and that accelerated the project in our minds because that is the first piece and there
was no federal funding for it probably accelerated the project by decade so now federal highway has
a route that that they prefer you know of how the new exits would look and and where they would
connect into downtown and where they start so we've given them now a road map to actually start
design so it was money well spent by this this body to to accelerate that on behalf of aldot
and federal highway so i do know recent conversations with director cooper with mayor battle
he has made a commitment to start the design of that i know miss martin our city engineer has had
some follow-up meetings with martin bartlett and leadership at aldot of how they kick that off what's
the scope of work start to look like but the good thing is is by you allowing us a couple years ago
to get ahead of that and provide them a road map now they have something to actually go design off
of so so we've really accelerated that by spending a couple million dollars of our money
it's affecting our city but i think that was money well spent
and what's the next next step then beyond that design we need to get federal and state get
federal funding but but the good news is once federal highway and aldot create a project in
into the national highway system for design now you have a project that is competing with all other
thousands of road projects across the u.s so then appropriations into that project is easy to do the
first step that's really really hard is to get you listed within that program and we've done that
other questions i was just going to comment when i was looking at the list of all the projects
whether they're happening or plan to be happening cover every bit of this city
and it's not a piece of the city not growing yes and i think we probably all have areas where we
hear from citizens that feel like they're the land that god forgot and obviously that's not the case
but right you know so this is really good to see so much of the city working for the city i agree i
think it's a well balanced plan especially on transportation i mean we're spending money in
roads in every one of your districts and it's not us trying to be balanced in your district and say
and be able to tell each of you hey we're spending money or district these are priority projects
based off traffic counts that we say this is where the money needs to be spent and i think it shows
the health of each of your districts you know it's not heavy to one district we say well that's where
the growth's at or that's where the traffic's at it is broad and everybody's getting some type of
improvement and when when do you think they'll start building the bridge because i get asked that
which park bridge the the pin one that goes sky bridge so that piece will bid
probably late spring early summer and then the way that cable span bridge will work is once we award
you will award that to a contractor the first thing is it will actually a lot of it will be
constructed off site so it will probably be a year after you award the contract before you'll see
pieces start to arrive and there's a reason behind that once a cable spin bridge and that's
the way you would design those you kind of link and log them together once they get here but two
is be minimal impact to governor's drive and you have in memorial parkway so really before i think
you're probably a year to say 18 months to a year maybe 18 months maybe really on when say a year
from now i think you'll start seeing foundations go up and you can kind of see where it's going
across but then we'll wait for the actual bridge builder to deliver those parts so two years is
yeah absolutely within two years you'll start seeing that skyline start to appear
anybody else all right mr davis you didn't have to be easy on me your last 2014 presentation
thank you so much for for the work you did on this and we'll look forward to
uh having you come to the next meeting yes ma'am thank you thank you
next item and last item is the presentation of the proposed fiscal year 2027 update to the 1990
capital improvement plan by the administration followed by increased discussions and input by
council with the mayor and administration officials mr hamilton
um
this is a pdf you know how to go to the
old guy having technology problems uh council members uh which before you is the 1990 capital
improvement plan for fiscal years 27 through 36 obviously the focus is on the near-term years
as you're accustomed to so uh this is funded primarily by sales and use tax revenue it's a
it's eight uh 18 percent of the three and a half percent sales tax so as you know full sales tax
is four and a half percent one one of those percentages is what you just heard about the
other three and a half percent is split a number of different ways and 18 percent of it comes into
to this fund there's also a number of other funding sources gas taxes uh transfers from other funds
as well as some leases and things like that so it's a wide variety of other little funding
sources that make up the rest of it so right now we're modeling a total revenue of 55.4 million
in uh in this account see projects this year at 95 million a big chunk of that is uh is debt
related projects and we have a net debt service this year of 5.5 million so beginning balance
of 1.3 million but in any balance of 3.3 so where where does that money go so this uh this fund
the biggest and primary thing that it does is maintenance and sustainment of our departments
that are providing services to the community so you see major infrastructure maintenance street
resurfacing is always the biggest piece of that but there's other other road maintenance drainage
maintenance but infrastructure maintenance at all uh that go into that that infrastructure
maintenance primarily executed by public works but not all of it some of that also gets transferred
over to to the engineering department they have some some functions that are that are actually
funded out of this uh out of this fund we also do fleet capital at 12.5 million one of the things
you'll see if you when you look at the capital plan uh that is the you know we have one big fleet
capital account that uh that we do most of the fleet sustainment with one of the issues that
we have had uh is kind of the uniqueness both in expense and the manner in which we acquire
fire apparatus and so while not in 27 you'll notice starting in 28 and beyond uh i've actually
modeled in a separate line specifically for fire apparatus that's a that's an area that we've been
particularly challenged in and we're finally getting to a place where we can focus on that
and so uh and because of the order length time they're actually dropping orders today or right
now that won't be filled for several years and so those that funding in the out years lines up just
fine with the acquisition timeline the sociophi rep rest so it's not a problem that there's no
money in 27 specifically for that it picks up in 28 and will be will be in good shape you also see
uh significant investment in parks and rec facility improvements some public safety facility
improvements and then also i've always highlighted council improvement funds
that are consistent with prior year funding so what are some of those major projects right now
already under construction so for the most part you won't see these in the updated plan because
they're actually have already started and they're they're funded from prior years so a number of
projects down in john hunt park uh another a number of other places of course a big one happened
right outside this window over here but those are things that are under construction right now that
are funded out of the 90 capital plan some things that we have in design and i would tell you this
list is not intended to be all inclusive i've tried to capture just kind of the larger the larger
things that are in the plan but in design right now is the renovation of the shower center
the gulf of a shipping stadium the depot park as well as a storage facility for public works
and that that's you know one that you know it's not necessarily as much fun as building a park or
greenway or things but uh one of the issues that polo crooks has had is is their ability to acquire
and store sufficient materials for significant winter weather storms because of lack of storage
space we've been basically buying salt in bags which is about the least efficient way to do it
it's much better to be able to store that in bulk and so that storage building while it'll do a
number of things for the biggest is actually providing storage capacity to begin getting
those materials in bulk less expensive and in larger quantity so we can be prepared to deal with
with winter weather and then some other upcoming things that are in uh in the near term but out
years in the plan we've talked about replacement a number of fire stations also getting a building
for the process south precinct in quite a few uh park repairs and improvements and things one of
the things this this fund uh primarily does what we would kind of classify as our quality of life
infrastructure and of course a lot of that is the facilities that parks and recreation manages for
us um you know if you spend backwards a few years ago we all really kind of admitted ourselves that
we were behind in just total capacity of those kinds of facilities and so we worked pretty
aggressively in this plan to get lots of new facilities built to meet growth and that will
continue uh but we would in our assessment we've largely caught up to that that deficit we still
have work to do so i'm not saying we're all the way there but in terms of the pace at which we've
needed to add new capacity we we're doing much much better but it's also important that we not
forget the stuff that was already there and properly maintained and we have a lot of facilities
that are now at an age that needs some sort of repairs or renovations when you look at the
details in the plan there's a whole laundry list of park facilities where our park inspectors have
gone out and identified uh in some cases fairly minor things but important in other cases a little
bit more uh larger scale that need to be done just to fix repair improve some of our existing
parks and so you'll see a laundry list of parks that that have some funding that's uh that's
scaled based on what the parks and directors identified as indeed in those parks and they're
all over the city and so we'll continue to do that so it's it's a you're seeing just a little bit of
shift of uh being able to refocus a little bit more resources on maintaining what we already have
versus uh building new stuff that doesn't mean we go to zero and building new stuff it's just we've
kind of we've largely caught up but there's uh like i say there's a few places where we need to
continue to do that and i'll be happy to address any questions that you have questions for mr
hamilton uh we've had a lot of interest lately in the library it would appear in 2031 we have
35 million set aside for the library and we do and so um one of the things that is really kind of a
question mark that's hanging out there that uh that we need some others to help figure out is
really kind of what the county is doing with rebuild of the courthouse and you say how does
the rebuild of the courthouse rebuild of the courthouse tie to the library well we have offered
to help them with some temporary facilities uh to to facilitate their move once we understand their
timing and what they're doing we think some of those facilities may actually help our situation
library so i'm in a little bit of a holding pattern while the county goes through their
decision making process and once we understand those timelines better i'll be able to come back
to you and and to the library board with a little more detailed concept for how we think we might
address the issues here downtown i did put a plug out there in the out years uh to build a new
branch downtown but one of the one of the issues we have with the downtown library branch is it's
more than a library branch it's also the central offices and archives and other things that are
really county-wide facilities they are not necessarily huntsville's downtown library branch
and so you know the how we deal with those two different components of one building may there
may be a better strategy and something a little bit more affordable than what than some of the
options we've previously been presented so on that one yes i think we all agree that that we've got
to improve that situation but we need just a little bit more time so we can understand some
of the other dynamics downtown and then come back to you with a good plan for how to deal with it
i think the important part is that there is a placeholder there for that 35 million for the
library and then with regard to hbd precinct construction we have 200,000 in 27 3.5 and 28
2.3 and 29 is that the south precinct it is so it will be spread out over those we're looking at
a three-year project what i've done there is one is you know we've kind of gotten you know obviously
a lot of those types of things uh we've funded with debt out of this plan in this particular
case we're in a position where i think some of those kinds of projects we can fund cash which is
better anytime we can do with cash instead of debt we're in a better position the way you see
it lined up spread over three years really aligns with the duration of the project so that first
little batch of money is just to pay for design and we already own the land so now it's just a
matter of designing the building and then the the way that construction project will line up it'll
go over multiple fiscal years and so i can align the funding over multiple fiscal years thank you
and i was glad to see that there's allocations both for renovations at Buchanan Park and Willow
both of those are much needed thank you for that anybody else mr cling
uh
we can and we have you know for example in some of the dialogue at a recent council meeting there
was uh issue related to the flooring there on the first floor and we actually funded that that
repair uh they had not at the time they came and spoke to you they weren't anticipating that but
we'd actually had some money set aside in this capital plan for maintenance uh at the facility
and so we were able to fund that that floor repair so there's other kind of those kind of small
examples why they may not be a huge dollar amount they are important to the public and so yeah we'll
continue to engage with them and find opportunities to do that kind of stuff
also
and
i might be putting themselves too thin between drake avenue and clinton avenue and
if there is going to be a new building built someday could it just be at that location versus
going elsewhere we'll we'll bring a layout for those new stations to council you know that
there is no fire station that operates in isolation they are all interconnected to each other based on
their zones uh and so what uh you know the situation we actually have at station three is
that its zone right now where it's positioned is wholly redundant to surrounding stations and so
we've you know we've discussed for a number of years that it needs to be repositioned a little
bit further north of jordan lane to better position it relative to other stations and so we'll come and
lay all that out for you we're not going to leave any part of that of the city there uh in a gap in
fact i would say much of its response zone will remain the same not 100 but a large portion will
it just needs to tie in better to where the other stations are and so we have our our resources
position a little bit better but the the neighborhood and i've talked to citizens down
there as well and and we will make sure that they have a fire station as well within the
response zone required to make sure their needs are cared for any questions or comments all right
that our two-hour meeting became a three-hour meeting but we've gone through a lot of information
and again action will be taken at the september 24th meeting we appreciate all the presentations
that have been made and thank everyone for their patience as we went through them so your turn